five
four
three
two
i'll just say this right at the top guys
she's guilty
all right
this is a pro johnny depp podcast i just
want to make that very clear
let's go thank you i'll tell you what if
there's one man that could get
amber off
it's our boy let's go
he could do it
welcome everybody it's monday
may 23rd we're in an empty office which
i'll explain in a second but first a
quick quick thank you to hello fresh
uh that we love all super troopers love
hello fresh look at this spicy pork bowl
with cilantro
charred poblano salsa fresh
and smoky cream
bro i'm sorry what yeah hello fresh this
is just one of the delicious meals
that you know we've tried through
hellofresh and they've got over 50 menu
and market items to choose from you
could try something new every week get
16 free meals plus three free gifts with
code
h3tv16
at hellofresh.com
h3tv16 thank you
welcome everybody
we had a massive covid scare kova's been
going around man like the like the play
like a virus
um
poor ian got coveted again
ian how you feeling
about as good as i look
you look great
thank you so are you feeling really sick
though
yes
you want to tell me the symptoms what's
what are you experiencing
um
sort of existential malaise
and
runny nose
wait hold on go back to existential
malaise what is that
you know just thoughts of being
like
i was looking out the window this
morning and i was like
what if someone else
is having this same view
out the window
at another point
in our galaxy
and we would
never know that the other one exists
right isn't that crazy i don't know if
that's a symptom of covet but that is
nuts dude
yo covet sounds kind of cool dude so kel
coven sounds like a trip bro
there's an ethan out there hosting a
podcast
except he's funny and skinny
and you'll never know like you'll never
know what that guy's doing
that's interesting man that's really
that is existential malaise
emma so yeah and then i just felt dizzy
how's the taste
and i'm losing it oh my god not again
oh we're gonna have to get you to eat
some fika fish to bring up you know and
lemon juice shots and whatever
it's like when you lose um
yeah i'm i'm losing
all ability to register food i will have
to eat only fika fish because that's
like the only thing on the planet
with enough power to
maybe make me feel something again
it's like i wonder um paddles for my for
my taste buds i wonder what
kind of
what kind of health you'd be in if you
ate exclusively fika fish do you know
what i mean like i wonder
i wonder what that would
what kind of life you'd be living if you
did that for a year straight it's like
the carnivore diet but like that it's
like you know
what would that be like
i don't i don't don't don't don't ask me
to find out because i would you know i
was gonna say tune in to the podcast
for the next year ian will be eating
exclusively
steve jablonski running up my venmo
account
i'll be as much fika fish as i need to
well we we we hope we wish you a steep
uh a fast recovery you know
we think hyundai created this uh
outbreak
some of us believe that he got us good i
don't think it was good he said he had
coveted who else had covet oh i don't
know but just like because he was far
away from ian and he only came in for a
minute he was sitting by me and you
so me and me and av didn't get sick and
we were right next to him but he did
have kovid
he found out
okay
and then ian you didn't do anything
right you didn't expose yourself in any
way
so the only coveted exposure that i've
been informed so honda came in here
acting like a friend of the show
all gracious everyone was loving uh
loving on honda meanwhile he's spreading
a deadly plague
in secret and nobody caught except poor
ian
who was sitting probably furthest away
from him
the last knockdown
right last knock down in the ring one
for the road
i thought that all the rounds were over
i guess not
you know i gotta i gotta deal with this
guy hundar he's knocked out two of my
crew members now
but then um didn't someone else have a
covet scare or was it just the hundard
thing
because then maybe a bunch of people at
the fight a bunch of the fighters got
sick
bunch of them yeah
that's nuts yeah i've been dodging that
[ __ ] like neo i'm good i haven't got
covered yet which is nuts too man
well there you are uh olivia's back
welcome back olivia you know
it's so it's so nice to have you back
it's it's sad to do it under this uh i
mean we all love the counsel of rick
don't get me wrong but um
we have a lot planned for your inaugural
return episode so we'll do that on
wednesday i think we'll be clear by then
olivia oh so good to be back feeling
good welcome back
how was uh so you're done with school
you've uh
you graduated you got your degree
i have two credits left i'll finish here
but yes i did my thesis and everything's
done in ohio what was your thesis about
it was a play called stupid [ __ ] bird
it was a modern metatheatrical
adaptation of chekhov's the seagull
it was super fun loved it we spent all
last year picking it so i was really
happy i got to do it
that's the most college thing i've ever
heard
well i've met a theatrical adaptate
modern adaptation of yeah of
the whole thing just the whole thing you
know i mean we had to do so many like
writing things about it i feel like i
have a lot of scholarly sentences to go
with that play and um what what did you
get on your on your final
oh we got an amazing
so wait what is this title of our
podcast is this a direct rip of emily's
it says it says lawyers react alive depp
testifies
johnny is that really her total or full
title you said i was kidding i don't
know
it's hard to say oh he did all full copy
because he said copy paste emily's title
okay i that was a clear joke i felt you
can't copy paste like a carbon copy of
hers
well anyway we're always joking about
emily because she always has like uh you
know
she has like 200 000 live streamers or
something
so i jokingly said
just copy emily's
[Laughter]
i said ethan what are we titling the
episode today and you replied with
nothing but
copy paste emily's oh my god that's and
then you didn't say anything else i mean
what i had no further instruction fair
enough fair enough you you you fault you
are you're a loyal lieutenant you follow
orders man i appreciate that grumpy
you'd be an asset to the russian army
oh yeah
um
should we change the title though
[Laughter]
it's kind of funny
non-lawyer reacts live i mean it's just
big dumb idiot reacts live you can't
have the same exact title
all right i mean what should it be uh
yeah just
i vote lawyer reacts you like lawyer
reacts i love lawyer reacts so let's do
let's do
oh my god
there's a lawyer reacting to this
somewhere not on this show
why don't we just react to emily
just watch emily's stream yeah how are
we going to get views doing that
reacting to a lawyer reacts
lawyers let's go we're reacting
i'm uh a lawyer for content court i
don't know if that counts but well you
have some law experience i was yeah my
father's lawyer i was a pre-law for like
one semester yeah and then lina was
didn't was she had like a paralegal or
something lena was pretty no i would i
was oh she was medical yeah yeah
doctor reacts
to john you know i like so so lawyers
react live johnny depp versus amber
adept testifies and then instead of
question marks exclamation
okay we're gonna do that
and then now it's different
now it's more clickbaity all right i
just changed it
johnny depp
dude she oh my god you guys but
isn't the um
isn't the algorithm gonna be like what's
with this channel smaller channel with
the exact same title
smaller channel
i guess we don't realize
yeah check out the views for days bro
damn
depp testifies
maybe oh you know what i gotta do maybe
swap the order amber heard versus johnny
depp
oh definitely and then you can remove
trial day 20. so it's less
it's less copying
so the algorithm be like these guys are
these guys are good
shout out to the gifting subs you guys
are legends v-ray facts foe whatever
yeah you got a tricky name let's be
honest
oh and then
okay amber no sweet potato yep
swiped it swapped it around all right
let me let me refresh did you did you
update it i did
oh yeah this is good lawyers react live
depth testifies amber heard vs johnny
depp
this is awesome you guys alright so
as you guys know
right out the gate you know um i have it
open you can just you know so people in
the sea maybe just put it up while we
talk so like you know
it's not click bait
get you just put it on a square in the
council of ricks or something
don't have the technology okay no
problem
um as you guys know this is mostly a
social experiment to see how high we can
get the views
uh again
this is a pro johnny depp stream but to
be honest let's be honest guys i mean
you know
i don't want to say i don't want to piss
people off but uh
let's just be honest um
i don't know what you're going for here
i really i really
people just can get angry if i tell the
truth right now
i know
yeah
let's just say i really [ __ ] care a
lot about this trial and you know as you
should it's important and that's why
we're watching it today
and not because everyone else has like
100 at least i don't pretend okay i'm
sorry but all these people watching
these streams who have hundreds of
thousands of viewers i they don't
[ __ ] care okay
i do i'm the only one that does and
maybe emily
um someone's anyway uh welcome everybody
to the show
um
so olivia's back we'll we'll welcome you
back more officially on wednesday but
it's nice to have you back
thank you thank you very nice to be back
are you sad to be done with school
though and back at work
um definitely not sad to be back at work
um
it's always hard saying goodbye to your
friends
obviously that was tough
but i feel very lucky that i'm going
into the world with this job you have
another family here waiting everybody
was missing you
oh it was the nicest thing ever i missed
everybody
when i left college you know i cried
like a baby dude when i said bye cried
so much
we were driving out and
the group of boys that like we all had
little crushes on were right in front of
our car as we were like scream crying
down
down the
down the street would you say you were
ugly crying
i would say we were ug
crying i had to leave a good impression
one last time
you know i have an interesting anecdote
i want to share with you guys because
over the weekend
um
why is it go it goes up what the views
are confusing me guys it was at 25 and
then went down to 23. we got to get a
hold of this okay what is happening
right now
it's going up and down no don't do the
bell for down
the ballot the bell is for increased
views only
okay
it's got it because
amber's name is first
you think so it's gotta be there's no
other reason
maybe it's because it's a carbon copy of
emily's title because nobody cares about
this trial
you can't honestly say that
go ahead ab you got something to say
yeah dan this is a once in a lifetime
experience this is like imagine growing
up in the 90s and watching the oj trial
live but you get to comment on the
internet with it that's it this is a big
deal okay trial of the century maybe or
two maybe it's because we're not
watching it here go ahead put it on and
i'll tell my story while it's placed
particularly
okay so that i've seen we've called you
know here she is uh little films about
the making of this is amber turd's uh
witness
right
this is catherine arnold who's an
entertainment industry consultant
okay that's not a real job
dan had to explain that to me
he already asked and i said pretty much
the same thing there's a majority of the
actors that had strong roles in film to
participate both in the posters and the
artwork and also participate at
dc fandom and ms heard was not invited
to either be in the poster or be at the
event and in fact they told you turn it
up a little bit dan
now can can this hurt amber's career not
being allowed to be in any of the
promotional materials
absolutely
it means that nobody knows about her she
doesn't have the same part in the film
it's not going to take her on to her
next movie
she's not being associated with the
tremendous going down what's happening
right now you guys for this
you know
movie that everybody's looking forward
to hello
watching the [ __ ] where are you where is
everybody campaign i apologize how have
the deaf world when statements affected
any other films or tv guys it's not
people are saying we don't care it's not
about you so
when will you understand that
statements
you know after or around the time that
aquaman won
i came out she was in the the tv show
called the stand it was based on a
stephen king where is everybody so
big okay hold on we got to change the
title
this is this is going sideways
this is all going sideways guys all
right new title
final verdict that was that was good
we got to take lawyers react we got to
drop that okay there's no lawyers here
nobody's even buying that [ __ ] all right
get out of here
all right
final verdict live
we gotta go that route right
or no johnny depp on stand live
our live exclamation mark johnny depp
takes the stand
i vote for that one thank you boom
that's it live exclamation johnny depp
takes the stand
all caps
uh just live all caps
yeah
this is this is again [ __ ] it's going
down
we've got like way less views than
normal and it's just dropping guys what
are you doing this isn't stop it's not
about you we don't care
live johnny depp takes the stand
that's good all right so let's just talk
about other stuff and uh i want to tell
the story
so let's see
um
so basically we're not pleasing anybody
this is not going good okay
so this weekend i went to my brother's
stop with the tomatoes i'm gonna talk
about something else
guys it's not about you
this is about a social experiment i'm
trying to farm these other [ __ ]
idiots
you guys just gotta not leave
just leave if you don't want to watch
just leave the stream open we're trying
to farm these [ __ ] morons that just
watch the [ __ ] all day don't you
understand it's not about you it's about
the show you have to care about the
welfare of the show
come on what kind of fans are you guys
just go grocery shopping or something
we're trying to get the people watching
emily's stream those morons okay we're
going up you're honestly working okay
good stay honest
okay very right right stay honest stay
honest okay
anyway i do want to tell this anecdote
but can they see that we're watching it
dan yeah it's okay good good good
so um
so
okay don't blow it ethan it's going up
okay focus
so
my brother's getting married and we had
a bachelor party this weekend oh hell
yeah and big bear
and i drove my new car there you guys
know i got the all-electric porsche yeah
hassan's car
well it's my car now it's my car yeah
the one that has song the one i'm known
for dan you got to stop with that [ __ ]
dude you got to stop with that go ahead
go ahead jack
it's ethan's car yeah thank you yeah dan
you got it you got to stop it
it's ethan's car what kind of car is it
it's a porsche
porsche can for electric 4s it's a
different color and the interior is
different dan
plus ethan's driving it so it's cooler
thank you bro
anyway the point is
you know tesla kind of brainwashed you
that um they've got these electric
superchargers they have this incredible
network
but the truth is
i learned that there's this there's a
company that really blew my mind it's
called electrify america and every car
but tesla every electric vehicle shares
um
the same infrastructure
which is kind of like okay tesla
whatever the [ __ ] fine keep that [ __ ]
away from these ones but the truth is
these are way faster man
i i got brainwashed bro i plugged this
[ __ ] in my car was charged like
i went and got a sandwich i didn't have
time to finish the sandwich before it
was fully charged
and what's so i looked i was like man
what is this electrify america it's
pretty incredible
and that
this is gonna
this is the interesting part
it's owned by volkswagen and when they
had that huge emissions scandal when
they were faking
uh the emissions of their cars
one of the
um
punishments for them
was that they had to build all this
infrastructure for electric vehicles oh
wow so volkswagen is is being forced to
invest billions of dollars
into these incredible electrify america
stations that are awesome so uh silver
lining that's it basically that that's
the story but i thought that whole thing
was a little interesting that is
interesting yeah so shout out volkswagen
uh how was the bachelor party
everyone was asleep by
11.
[ __ ] lit
yeah it wasn't it was cool though it was
[ __ ] dope it was sick
um
and theodore has our theodore's sick man
he's got a sore throat and he's sucks
miserable
and i had to get he wanted to watch the
new paw patrol movie when he was sick
because he's sick so
i had to get paramount plus did you guys
know that paramount has a streaming
service now that is now my 25th [ __ ]
streaming service
that's the one that that has the halo
show that everybody's making fun oh
so yeah so they have they have exclusive
area we have exclusive content um
yeah i wish uh
all right anyway i guess we should watch
this and see let's just put this on
let's see what happens okay let's listen
go ahead as you look to see comparable
actors so you can kind of it's not a
distinct actual this is going to happen
but this is the probability with a
reasonable certainty that with the right
management team that she had and her
acting ability and her looks and the
press that she was getting and should
have continued to get that her career
would have been similar to these other
actors
have you used that method in other cases
in which you've been an expert on
damages yes i have
who did you select as comparable i think
you need some brown noise
you think so that helped a lot of times
that we're in superhero films i think
it's too early
so i i looked at jason moab i love the
brown noise i looked at gal gadot who
was uh
tomatoes in chat i looked at
um
anna de armas who was in um
blade runner thank you blade runner
i looked at zendaya who was in spiderman
and i looked at chris pine who was in
star trek and also wonder woman about
the you know similar age range
all attractive actors always so she is
basically arguing that somebody's career
was already going down prior to the
article being released oh
he got fired from his next uh pirates
gig didn't he
i
i'll double check that i'm sorry but
johnny depp's career was not going down
management team who are you what's your
job again and we've heard from mr dan
take that off screen with the [ __ ]
[Music]
q scores are related to the actors
viability in the consumer's
mind if you will how well known or how
much they're coming up in conversation
and so mr benny did not look at time
periods of the actors that i compare
them with to the film when it came out
so like right after the success of their
big films you find this lady
but more i triangulated this lady that
she'll have no work after this it
doesn't coincide from actor to action
scores are
said we'd be getting views today that
turned out to be a lot after each of
those
individuals it didn't really work the
first time we did it yes it did
it went over 40
for 000 it was more than we've been
having recently months afterwards and
then if it comes back up
or another event that brings them into
that can we care the limelight again so
it's not about time it's a related to a
specific activity and what do you think
about this did not do that okay
what did your comparison show in terms
of films and what do you think about
this since they're breakout roles
do you have like rain or something do
you
that like be nice
i'm not quite sure look at his lawyer
bro dude this guy is the kill the
wickedest posture bro what happened with
these other actors he looks like a
meerkat man he just didn't know what the
[ __ ] going on
right right okay sorry
look at this
in terms of where their career went
after their star wars born moment then
they got some other good films and maybe
they got another film that performed
extremely well so it was a range but
they all were on an upward trajectory
without a doubt
and people are spamming everybody leave
with a reason i mean
turn this off tomatoes
why is this happening it's some
companies
yeah i think i think it's a hit with
their fans
um
you want me to watch this uh some clips
instead of just watching this lady
ramble about god knows what yeah this
guy was pretty interesting this
psychiatrist dr siegel
the face johnny depp and ben chu
make when dr spiegel starts acting like
he's high
mr depp's other portrayals
in movies that that affect your analysis
of processing speed only i've seen him
interact
on interviews and that was it right when
he wasn't in movies right
but willy wonka doesn't matter to you
you see in that movie charlie chocolate
factory
did you look at that one when you were
comparing this processing speed
what
this johnny death played willy wonka
what
yeah you gotta answer a [ __ ] why are
you trying to dodge the willy wonka
question
dude why are you dodging the willy wonka
question you'd be happy no i didn't see
willy wonka as her at i didn't see 21
jump street when it happened or i was
about no i did not
all right
you
mr depso
so he was saying
he was he was analyzing to say he was
high
and then they said well did you see him
in willy wonka
because he's crazy in that film mm-hmm
and he's like no i haven't seen that one
yeah but more interesting is the little
thing where he looks into my lips where
he licked his lips yeah no that that was
that was interesting man other
portrayals
did you look at that one when you were
comparing this processing speed
this guy's a horrible witness he looks
the other attorney like hell bro
what the [ __ ] are you doing what kind of
mannerism is that
let's go
yeah give me more of that this stuff's
great
he's literally crazy is there more of
him yeah i just sent another one oh i
love this man so the context of this one
is uh spiegel the psychiatrist implied
that johnny needed an earpiece to feed
him acting lines was a indication of
cognitive defect but uh
this guy's just willing to say anything
man
earpiece
what you found hard to believe sir was
that you guys hidden gatorade
the man you're a doctor man drink water
every line of the script was was pumped
through an earpiece where did you ever
get the idea that ever that occurred
that's what i have been that's what i
read and the court review the court
evidence that's where i got it
and
um
you know whether marlon brando used an
earpiece
whether isn't he dead
oh my god bro dude oh my god so the
answer is no he does not use one now oh
no i just did what the [ __ ] the past
tense
again i know nothing i will concede to
you i know nothing about acting
i will concede to you 100
if that is the standard and people are
done that's acting then i apologize and
that was wrong on my part
if that's an expert man this guy's an
expert i'm wrong i don't know
okay
let's go with that no further questions
all right how long has you either are
you actually a doctor
well
what do you define as doctor
this guy was very combative and like
defensive throughout the whole time he's
on the stand right here he calls johnny
an idiot
wow
a little note
yeah which i thought was interesting he
you said he was an uh expert he's
actually not allowed to be called an
expert in the court
because amber heard's lawyers wanted to
propose him to be an expert in this
field
but uh johnny depp denied or their his
lawyers denied him being uh an expert in
the field and he got so mad and that
would have had to start bringing him on
i believe it was because none of his
works were published on the subject well
that's you know you have to have some
credentials to be considered a court
expert
it was pissed though is this what that
is circumstances this is where he calls
johnny an idiot decided to call mr depp
an idiot
under somebody called he's a deputy
idiot yeah you called mr deaf an idiot
in your deposition well i think oh okay
so i think it was in the context i think
it was
probably should read the context of it
because i think the context was and i'm
trying to think back and i'm trying to
think back okay and what i thought it
was related to was if you're coming to
some deposition
okay and again i'm thinking back so i
may you have it in front of you
i don't so i'm thinking back where he's
coming in from
europe for a deposition
uh video deposition that he gave and
he
took it overnight the night before and
what i think i said was that if you're
going to take a
if you're going to do a major thing
toward a trial that you're involved with
i think you would be an idiot to come in
the night before
all right so i ain't coleman's a deputy
idiot i certainly call that planning and
he i didn't call him an idiot so the
words so i mean he's an idiot are
mistranscribed
no i'm sure again if i said it that's
good it's a [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is he
who are you bro
why is the amber's legal team is just
like
so [ __ ] one line one snippet yeah why
does he seem like he's on meth too sure
was in the context i just said but again
you have it in front of you i don't yeah
um
is uh idiot a professional opinion
professional yeah is it a psychiatric
opinion
and that follows the goldwater rule
how does it follow though i just said
that i'm not rendering a professional
opinion
the goldwater rule is important because
um it prohibits uh psychiatrists from
commenting publicly on the mental
well-being of individuals without
actually
uh conducting a test is that a real like
profession is that like a regulated rule
or just kind of like a professional
courtesy rule i believe it's regulated
um whoa back for a minute
so i couldn't be like yo that dude is
[ __ ] nuts if i had a
huh
that's not
so idiot is not a professional opinion
is it your
practice to describe people as idiots my
practice described in my practice no i
don't describe people clinical my
clinical cases they were patients as
idiots or victims as idiots no sir but
you set for a deposition in this case
and and describe the plaintiff as an
idiot correct you gave me nine hours of
deposition and if i said the word idiot
it was an idiot in planning it wasn't
making him an idiot i don't know mr
depp's iq i don't know his overall
functioning so therefore if i said it it
was an idiot in planning which is what i
meant
so you did say you don't know his
overall functioning but you made some
testimony today as to
some evaluations you made relative to
his functioning you would agree with me
that it's
probably a good idea
to think about the questions that are
asked you in a court proceeding before
answering them
allowed to answer that question yes okay
so
what i meant by function what i said by
function i believe that his agent
reported how late he was showing up to
every movie while the cast is waiting
for him i believe that would be an
impairment if i showed up late for that
i would not be here right now i would
not have a job okay i believe the thing
was in terms of uh
balking out of treatment for substance
rehab that his doctor is prescribing for
him so if you're asking me if that's an
impairment this is the kind of guy who
just like prescribes his his uh
clients whatever they want you know what
i mean yo doc can i get like 20 zany or
can i get like 200 zany bars
where'd they [ __ ] find this guy
substantiated in that
i'm trying to understand all right
should we just move on i mean [ __ ] this
dude it's not good it's not working at
all
all right let's do i mean i if we do a
vote and let's say it has to be
over 80 percent move on
dan i've never seen dan type so fast in
my life
you guys ready
we need a 80 percent
move on
okay
can we cut all this out post ten
we just got this whole part of the show
you wanna just start over
should we just start over and end the
stream and just do a new stream do we
haven't pretend like none of this ever
happened i don't think we percent move
here
go ahead
oh
it's 78 you guys let's keep watching
let's go let's go
all right what else you got for me
sorry guys the people have not spoken
you got any other interesting um grumpy
no those are all the clips i got of uh
all right how about we'll we'll tune
back in if something interesting happens
what's going on now
uh it's probably just that consultant
lady still carelessly
think they're on a break
okay perfect
they're on a break guys what is this
what's going on in this pendant by the
way
uh that appears to
be a roman soldier no i think that with
a fat [ __ ] [ __ ] dude no that's a
woman her breasts oh her kitty's out
yeah and it's likely athena uh or well
why are you gendering her dan just
because she has a titty don't mean she
can't have a [ __ ] too i like the roman
soldier with the massive [ __ ] that
that makes more sense you know that's
the but what is it if it's not a fatty
that's the long digit the genital region
was exposed
no jordan
oh this is a king because there's a
crown dude he [ __ ] the king with the
fatty bro oh well she she got a titty i
forgot what's she stroking herself
absolutely
i think that translates to prepare to be
[ __ ] by the long dick of the law
sick semper tyrannis
all right well we're going to wait for
them to come back meanwhile we do have a
lot of other stuff to discuss guys
welcome everybody to h3 podcast we're
going to do the show now although guys i
got to say move it on is going down but
okay
we'll see what happens um at the top of
the show
uh
dan a little shout out to dan here
liven up the situation
this has been going on and i'm what do
you think about all this dan
somebody's been photoshopping dan's face
onto everything he's taken over the
subreddit i only saw it last night for
the first time and i mean here's dan's
face on everybody well taken aback
my face on ian is just ian
right it does not look that different
does it
[Laughter]
um it's spider-man with dan it's jesus
with dan
it's olivia with dan this one was
disturbing
look at that one olivia
i think i look hot
um
there's been a lot of memes on the
subreddit too about it here yeah thank
you cam so what do what do you think is
this is this something that we can keep
doing here i mean here's today's
thumbnail dan
yeah you look pretty good as johnny dad
it's kind of dope
this is frightening though yeah me as
you is terrifying that i don't like
funker
that's like mia's amber isn't bad
if you shave the beard
so i guess keep it up it's a little
confusing but we love that
um another
another recurring
meme it's been a while since we talked
about mobility scooters you know with
the passing of mobility mary god rest
her soul
uh there's just not been many out there
that can challenge her but
take a look at this
we have an important piece of
information from your father
all right uh
that
uh symbol that we were looking at it's a
death to tyrants that's what booth said
when he killed lincoln
why the [ __ ] would they put that on the
wall
because it's virginia uh well i suppose
wait they're just giving a shout out to
the dude that killed lincoln
i mean i believe that that was a common
latin phrase
oh so my regardless dad are you trying
to spin this what are you doing
death to lincoln
the beautiful state of virginia
all right
i'm embarrassed for swearing for your
parents now
danny dad you want to call in and give
us a lecture on
death to tyrants
um anyway here is mobility mary his
cousin and the mobility jared
[ __ ] world is this dude shout out to
the horsepower on that thing though
number one dude is holding up traffic
that's not even a gatsby that's just
like
incredible
bro how you
trying to get over
[Laughter]
how can it have that
horsepower
and if you catch that thing going
downhill you are [ __ ]
you are not stopping
oh someone said that's what brutus said
when he killed caesar
all right there you go that makes that
makes more sense dad well you got to
make it a weird political thing
yeah apparently in the courthouse in
virginia they just have a picture of
lincoln's
mangled
bloody dead corpse
his face blown out being with a giant
and then did you know booth had a giant
[ __ ] and tits
the el paso the guy has no option so
unless you're willing
what's this guy playing in the world is
this how's he how's he gonna use that
vote anyway i mean with peace and love i
don't see you dude
traffic towing a boat
i wonder if he jacked the boat
i know where he got him where did he get
a mobility scooter with a [ __ ] hitch
that's what i'm saying i just saw it's
got like he managed to like hitch it up
you can see here like what's going on
there
wow
my theory is that he doesn't need the
mobility scooter and he just
needed a way to pull his boat
so you think this is just an end to the
means this is the jack souped up
souped up the cheapest way to pull your
boat basically
i can't help but notice like half of our
council has dipped
half of our what look at the council the
council of rim oh well oh there's one
they come and go i mean as they they
serve at their pleasure dan i was just
letting my dog in yeah oh okay they
serve at their pleasure ian is the only
one who stayed because he can't move
where's sam
there's an extra seat for you sam
who's sam
right
anyway shout out to um the spirit of
mobility insanity lives on so
that's [ __ ] incredible man
how is that even possible dude i don't
know
that's got to be florida right
yeah yeah i think that's a safe guess
so how does a scooter even have enough
torque i mean that's what i'm saying man
fascinating stuff guys welcome back to
the h3 podcast
um we are on break right now
thank you
uh 40 minutes if you can believe it into
this uh
train wreck of an episode um
this really is a train wreck i'm sorry
guys i can only imagine people who
aren't watching live we're gonna come
try to watch the show
you can just skip this the first part
you should just do a time stamp just
skip all of this skip this just skip
this part
you know this this is just dead air
it's right dead air
so i guess we should do that read but
you know okay so i got rid of the
rolls-royce and then two days later
austin mcbroom posted this
dude that's the exact same [ __ ] car
that's a black colon in
two days later
there's a really good chance
that austin driving my old car
that's hilarious
i wet my buggers under the seat all day
i was about to say how much have you
farted in that car dude so many times
bro smell that seed austin i dare you
i'm just kidding about the boogers
[Music]
how does it feel to get my sloppy
seconds though it's gotta be they were
so desperate for that car i returned it
to rolls royce
it makes sense two days later
how the [ __ ] these guys affording you
know this car is very expensive these
guys don't
they're putting on a fake festival
how the [ __ ] you guy where where's their
money coming from i'm genuinely
confused so shout out catherine for the
big 30 surprise
a bankruptcy speed run
damned and actually that means their
payment would be even higher than mine
because of the price increase
because they they paid me
oh [ __ ] i can look up the vin number
you're right love oh
yeah
i should do that
i should i should look up the vin
i can wait i can actually do that i can
have ela look it up
i have the old insurance form at my
house
that'd be hell of a turnaround time for
the dealer man well because they're so
short on cars they probably had they
have a waiting list you know right
they're like yo we just got one in stock
yo i'm gonna message you though um
on the table
by the entrance
is my old insurance card
for the rolls
can you tell me the pin
this is this unethical
no as long as we keep it private yeah
i'm not going to share it yeah i mean it
was your car previously technically
this is so awesome dude it's gotta be my
car it's gotta be
didn't you even
didn't
the place that you returned it was uh
by where they live wasn't it
i don't know but there's there's only
like one certified rolls-royce dealer in
la it's a place in beverly hills oh okay
and it's like
i'm not sure that where else you would
even get it they sell they do like
exotic cars
and they're like an official rolls-royce
dealer so i'm pretty sure they would
have to have got it from there
it would make sense
they totally got your car i feel like
there's a 90 chance that's my old car
oh that's awesome
okay well shout out uh austin good job
getting that [ __ ] money sink
that car sucks dude and it's so
expensive nice just financial decision
idiot
all right um
oh shout out to j there's a lot of stuff
here going on shout out to drake
who is in bed with literal [ __ ]
i don't want to say it but you guys know
what you guys know about steak
he he made an exclusive steak drake
twitch channel
that's in two days we should watch that
[ __ ] johnny depp
now there's a reaction stream i can get
behind let's watch draked
staked
oh ela's calling me [ __ ] hold on
hey you're a lot we're live right now
hello oh
this is this episode [ __ ] sucks
so much dead air nobody's here
johnny depp's on [ __ ] break he was
supposed to take the stand
hila uh you're live right now yeah
oh i am yeah
so here's
so here's what we're strategizing
we are theorizing that um austin mcbroom
has my old car and we can actually fact
check that if we if you can get me the
vin
the vin number
yeah so my
i just took the insurance card it's in a
bag i put by the way
okay okay okay so so get the don't say
it on don't say it just type it to me
but there's the insurance card so it
should say the vin number
yeah
you see it
yo we got the ben bro this is awesome
this is gonna say awesome mcbroom
is it would be the same event
yeah it would be the same vin it doesn't
change yeah
it's like it's like social security
number for vehicles
[Music]
are you watching the show
we're doing really good coverage of the
johnny depp trailer numbers are insane
today that's what's happening yeah our
views are nuts bro
every time we watch we lose 10 000
viewers
but i'm i'm i'm convinced that that the
viewers are out there we just got to
find them
[Music]
interesting that you choose to do it
again
yeah no i'm uh it's interesting isn't it
well because why are all these other
guys getting all the views where's our
views i don't get it azmin gold like
what i mean they're invested they've
been following the trial you don't even
know what's going on i'm invested no
you're not damn stop i'm invested bro
don't tell them don't i don't want them
to know that
for all their aware i've been following
since day one i know everybody true they
probably haven't picked up
[Music]
i sent it and i'm actually in the middle
of it okay
okay thank you thank you so much all
right all right all right thank you good
morning
all right bye
okay so now how do we check the vin
[Music]
i got it i got it guys i got it
all right i'm going to send it in the oh
you'll send it in the podcast chat
all right
can somebody
in the council uh
do a little look up on that
there's there is there you guys can drop
money you know and see if it costs money
to do a vin
can you search the plate too
well the plate would be different
well no because isn't your previous
plate still registered to that car
i'm not sure that it would have his
information on it though would it now
he'd get new plates wouldn't he yeah he
would get new plates when he bought it
really
no i don't
yeah i don't think it changed or i don't
know oh [ __ ] she's back
let's see let's just see what she's
saying
guys don't leave i swear to god don't
leave
let's just see what they're talking
about
okay boring next um
all right so while we work on getting
that vin number fact checking
so drake
the drake stream is on
the 26th that's thursday mean me and
hassan i think me and hassan can oh
enjoy that nice
let's go drake
cool dude
it's [ __ ] cool huh
i hope he plays fortnite with ninja
again that's all i want out of him on
twitch
you know what's crazy is is ninja's
whole career dude basically and thanks
to drake
no no no at all because i thought like
after that drake stream he went from
like thirty thousand yeah like a million
well sure i'm sure that boost yeah that
definitely drake wouldn't have played
with him if he wasn't already drake made
you in other words fortnite was the most
popular game at the time and he was
definitely the best so even without
drake i mean he's got a braless wife
that serves some sandwiches bro you've
seen those titties to her top bro i was
like life is made
sometimes i see hila walk around without
a brawn i'm like [ __ ] she walk around
without a bra
and she serve you sandwiches
sometimes and i don't even have to ask
her yo
you gotta tweet about that dude you
gotta tweet about that
i gotta let the world know bro
everyone's gonna be so jealous man i'm
jealous
that's the so funny
someone's saying
yeah the plate is registered to you the
vin is registered to the car so is
anyone on on the venn search right now
yeah i'm trying okay good good good
we're 50 of the way they're getting this
bro i'm begging please say austin
mcbroom please
and would it already be updated if they
just got the car like a few days ago
probably not
probably not
we'll have to check off periodically
this lady is boring she's got [ __ ]
credentials
i'm not watching you lady do you only
with association with mr weldman correct
you don't know when the first time mr
depp learned about those statements
i don't know no
i have uh go ahead i have an update go
ahead his interior is red
that's not my interior how did you know
that i went to his instagram right now
show me the picture
[ __ ]
that sucks
[ __ ] i just paid 20 bucks to check yeah
well you're using the video you used our
card right it's just 20 bucks it's 49
you shouldn't spend your own money on
that dumb [ __ ] oh no that's that's
definitely not my car
[ __ ]
we [ __ ] we were so close see captioning
not
three available blindfold
your house oh here's the video okay i'm
sorry but that string on his bald ass
weird fade looks hella funny
looks like a little
his head looks like a hot dog back here
it's like a toothpick around a hot dog
or i mean it's
a toothpick around a hot dog
what are you going for there
what do you call the [ __ ]
huh plus floss okay
my brain in front of me i think but
nothing happened
what the hell is that
all right
[Applause]
dude
i don't know how these guys
are affording anything it's so because
you know what they're doing they're
spending that festival money
yeah yeah
they're burning right through that
festival money guys
okay
let's see what these goons are talking
about
let's see if the views go up guys let's
act like we know we're after the waldman
statements
the walmart okay interesting that the
waldman statements
caused any damages crazy does it
when you look at the time frame of when
the waldman statements came out and you
look at what was going on with ms hurd's
career prior to the statements that's
crazy after the statements it's very
clear to make that correlation that they
were caused by those statements and the
campaign that followed afterwards in
terms of the negative social nuts all
right that's an interesting thing the
witness this morning uh actually
described
the um
the notion of what's correlation and
what's causation yo what is that
difference correlation does not imply
causation doesn't no
i'm not an expert in semantics
it's not semantics but you're an expert
who is
between the waldman statements
and all the other activity that occurred
since then
yeah as i stated and very clearly wanted
to make sure that that everybody
understood was that it was a time frame
under you know between which the waldman
statements were made
and the negative decline in her career
started happening
and and
in discussions with her agents and her
says there was a very tight timeline and
a very close link that's not when those
statements came out and when everything
started pulling away from this hurt all
right tell me what's up
what you're talking about i'm just
watching the views are they going up dan
be honest with me
[Music]
you do not
put any causal
miss her do you well actually
both emily has 150 000 you tell me we
can't get a couple thousand of those
campaigns no because they're watching
her statistically 76. you guys can't
even break 80. that's nice on the social
media campaign it turns out
you're lying propagandist statements
you're pro you know who you are you're
pro amber
that's what's going on here in them so
that was another connection that i was
able to make between the defamatory
statements
and these negative negativity that the
studios and the product endorsements and
the television and the press
connected as well all right let's start
with that
if they're true they're not defamatory
correct right again that's outside the
scope of my expertise
all right
let's then go back to what you just
testified to and i think you said the
waldman statements appeared in hashtags
it's too [ __ ] boring guys let's just
check in if something interesting
happens okay i can't do this
i can't i can't i can't
i can't
okay
guys you want some financial advice this
may be austin mcbroom needs
about to buy a million dollar home so i
couldn't tell if this was a parody or
reel
but you guys take and tell me what you
think about to buy a million dollar home
for half the price the thing is you can
only do this if you know how to utilize
cryptocurrency so this is the house that
i'm gonna buy and it costs about 1.4
million so i'll have to pay around seven
grand a month but for this entire house
the total that i need to pay is
740k it's because of crypto for the down
payment i'll have to pay about 20 which
is 290k with the remaining 450k i'm
gonna put that into the anchor protocol
once i deposit the 450k it'll yield me
19 per year that's 88 grand a year now
divide that by 12 months and that's
going to make me 7.3 k a month just
enough to cover the monthly cost of this
mansion after it's paid off i'll have a
1.4 million dollar home plus be making
7.3k a month doing nothing if you want
to learn more about crypto check out my
bio
are you [ __ ] that dumb i can't tell
if it's a pretty no
it's
i mean it may be a parody hey bro do it
but
i'm gonna i'm gonna go ahead and just
say that that's probably 100 real well
if you're taking advice from a 15 year
old
on how to buy a house with crypto you
deserve to lose it all
um
okay well obviously a 20
return is like we kind of we talking
about it that's double what bernie
madoff was promising and you know what
happened with that guy uh there's no
such thing as a guaranteed 20 return i
think everyone would be rich
it's an infinite money fountain
you know
the stock market returns through ups and
downs
um
10 which is great right but like there's
ups and downs like right now it's down
like 17 this year um
so if somebody promises 20 return you
are being scammed
just there's no question
if anyone promises you a guaranteed
return of anything over like three
percent you're being scammed damned
but i love how it's just so obvious he's
like bro you don't understand crypto
dude
so wait what how do i get the twenty
percent put it in the in the anchor
protocol my dude oh okay anchor that
money
okay you anchor it right billion dollars
bank account [ __ ] anchors
you know how to utilize cryptocurrency
so this is the house that i'm gonna buy
and it costs about 1.4 million so also
he's kind of implying to commit mortgage
fraud because he's like it's gonna cost
1.4 million
you put down only what you need to
but you got to pay them the whole thing
bro
you gotta
no
he puts 20 down yeah and then he's just
saying his his crypto investment with 20
return
the returns on that so he monthly will
be equivalent to but you still need to
have his mortgage payment a hundred and
you still have to have 1.4 million
dollars right yeah i mean the whole
thing yeah
so it's kind of already kind of a tough
one there
yeah
by the way this is trending right now
logan paul doubles down on his plan to
become president
i would actually love that can you
imagine the dirt that will come out on
him if he runs for president
i don't know if that matters
well it'll be interesting for me anyway
i just mean we got dirt coming out about
people all the time nobody nobody cares
trump probably like r worded like 20
people yeah yeah no and they all they
said it they're like yo no he did that
yeah
i can't get over the fact that trump
literally said like that secret tape of
like i just grabbed him by the
i just grabbed him by the [ __ ]
when you're famous you can do that so
sick everyone's like dude it's just
locker room talk
boys will be boys i ain't never i've
never heard talk like that in the locker
room yo if your girl doesn't want to
sleep with you just [ __ ] take it by
force
be like yeah that's so true
it's locker room talk it's off the chat
off the chains dude don't have the
waldman
um i just want to make sure if johnny
depp goes up we don't miss it
yeah speaking of crypto [ __ ]
okay so uh gary vee had his big
conference
over the weekend
and um you guys know how i feel about
gary vee i mean listen a lot of people
like gary vee
i happen to think that he's a giant
i think he cares about making money for
himself and that's it
that's what i think about vee
um so he had the v uh v con
and
so how do you get into v con you have to
own one of his things or what's what's
the deal there yeah you have to own one
of his nfts
um cause that [ __ ] doesn't look that
rare because there's like 20 000 people
in the audience
all these [ __ ] people own v friends
i believe so let me double check dude
that's nuts
a whole stadium of idiots
is the perfect place what olivia
that is disappointing wait till you see
this
i think i have seen this it's majorly
disappointing
cso what's what's the price of entry
here ab please tell please don't tell me
that every single one of these absolute
[ __ ] goons has a viewfriend aren't
that isn't that shit's like super
expensive
all right it's cheap once it when it get
minted for the first time it's cheap the
resale value is high how many v friends
do you own
yeah do you own 50. yeah yeah tell me
the truth you won't be friends love i
won't judge you no i don't uh i wish i
did would have made some money
yeah well
people actually think making v for
owning v friends will make the money
don't listen there's one rich person in
here and he's on the [ __ ] tv
here watch this play the video
[Applause]
i really wanted to do something
extremely special for just the people
that were actually at econ
so we teamed up with rally i created
this remarkable new exclusive character
stop right there
this is the remarkable new thing he
wanted to go all out for all of his
people at vidcon something
extraordinarily special
he looks like the dude in little nicky
who's got boobs on his head
this is [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] he just spit in all your faces
he wanted to do something special so he
spent 30 seconds drawing this [ __ ] with
crayons you understand
but wait
go ahead love
it turns out it's way cheaper than i
thought apparently there's like a
separate nft not v friends they're
called the v-con
v-con ticket
and they're just 600 bucks okay that's
still a lot but
yeah so you can buy v-con tickets well
no that's not a lot because the the
the event has already been so that's
just really a resale value afterwards
which is funny
they're useless now no i think it use
wait i thought it you can use it again
next year no
it says vcon 2022 oh [ __ ]
so this is just a ticket so that's it
that shows you how [ __ ] dumb people
are actually willing to pay 600 for a
used ticket okay if you had a used
physical ticket the v con
so if you gave that someone they throw
it in the trash for you
but it does have this original art
beautiful art cam i mean you're a
graphic designer do you ever aspire to
make something this gorgeous
uh i mean certainly it can be good as a
style but uh that's that's not good as a
style well hold on before you judge do
you notice the green lines uh he did
stay within the lines and as i
understand it that is impressive
i i kind of prefer if you went outside
the lines personally but i mean oh i
have more if i'm gonna genuinely
critique this i have an issue with uh
the v con typeface and just like how
illegible it is but
maybe next year in 2023 he can hire me
to to scribble and crayon for him there
you have it
cam is making his services available to
you gary yep i i got a whole crayon box
for you man so are people actually
buying this after
after it's already happened
four days ago oh no no nobody's buying
it love
nope
rip yeah
so anyway guys so let's get back to this
super uh incredible opportunity for
everyone at v-con
very special by the way it's also an ad
with rally whoever the [ __ ] they are so
we teamed up with rally i created this
remarkable new exclusive character just
for v-con the viper
and
i decided to team up with them and
create a scenario where in the app you
can go and get a piece of this
fractionally no different than we did
with the sharing squirrel but for free
that's right all of you in attendance
now own a piece of original parts
through the rally app by just going
there
[Applause]
of it how many many people join in if
nine of you do it and you're gonna be
dividing it up if all of you do it like
i hope you do then all of you will be
dividing it by the attendees that are
actually here at vidcon congrats
enjoy
more fun surprises okay like you have to
be literally psychotic to say congrats
and enjoy
after saying you're splitting this
crayon drawing with 20 000 people
you're [ __ ] demented he's delusional
guys this man is congratulations
he's mentally ill
congrats enjoy it or well he's a cult
leader yeah i don't think he is at all
he's a cult leader enjoy it guys
also it's so obviously just a sponsor
they paid him way more than that shit's
worth to get all these people to sign up
for their app oh my god these this is
suckers these are the most valuable
uh converting people in the world and
you know what i guarantee he had people
going around to all these crypto scheme
website not schemes but i bet you this
is a website where like you can
uh you can own a piece of a nft
infraction so you don't have to drop 200
000 for it
and so this these are like the biggest
suckers in the crypto world so
they're probably paying like a thousand
dollar cpa on that [ __ ] you know what i
mean
so
congrats if all of you do it like i hope
you do then all of you will be dividing
it by the attendees that are actually
here at the time congrats
enjoy enjoy my brand enjoy enjoy enjoy
you probably have to put in your credit
card info and [ __ ]
enjoy my friends
and you know i really [ __ ] just [ __ ]
my pants when i saw this
a huge i just come on guys
you gotta stop defending garyvee
we gotta stop letting this [ __ ] slide
uh there's more from vikon though of
course there is
oh let's check in real fast what are
they talking about he looks animated
right
waldman as you said didn't talk about
defecation
oh defecation okay and you haven't
considered
how that
story
has
adversely impacted miss herd's career
that story you're going to ask me for a
causational link between that poop story
and her demise of her career i can't no
i'm not gonna do that nor can i you
couldn't do it
can i make it no i can't
and you can't do it with waldman
statements either can you well again i
did and i have and i stand by them so
you you did by just pointing out the
time frame are relatively close
the time frame and the instigation and
and if you will the rallying of the
forces
boring i heard they say poop and i
[ __ ] perked up but then
you know
gary says the market crash is one of the
best things that could ever happen to
crypto well of course it is
you know
because because
when you're talking to a master con man
no matter what happens it's the best
thing that could happen to the market
the crash is better than the price is
going up by the way so that's actually
really convenient for him
yeah let's see
the best thing that has happened to us
this will clean out
some of the
very
dangerous i would call it behavior that
captures all of us in it
it's not fun when your assets go down on
paper that's not fun
i'm sure some of you are in the stock
market too
there's other things coming after that
so it is what it is
but
the timing is remarkable
because now a lot of the good work gets
done
a lot of the real learning gets done
a lot of the innovation gets done the
next two three years for web 3 will be
remarkable
i ask
in the opening keynote for all of you to
double down on something very important
which is education
i think my message
which i just happened to sell he's been
confused because of how angry education
on what what do you want people to learn
about it's just a [ __ ] nft bro
look how much do you want people to
learn about it
yeah that he sells exactly this is just
the floundering of a con man dude
desperately trying to keep his cultists
the i get a college debt
i
am not thrilled with the current way
that america and many other countries
sell education
i believe in education more than
anything
it is why we went on a four-month
journey to how to set up a meta mask how
to buy ethereum and many in this
audience
went through that journey
and not only one with what do you use
ethereum for
buying v friends exactly
it's incredible all roads lead all roads
lead back to garyvee
he cares about everything that makes him
money incredible but one in many other
great communities like many of you
minted board ape many admitted world of
women many of you did many other things
right now if you're here
you've got a baseline education
you've got a baseline education
this is when you have to triple down on
your education so he's talking about how
he cares about education it seems that
he's only talking about nft education
yeah crypto he's not talking about like
like history right no yeah he's also
talking about he wants free education
but he's like
not mine education but
pay for my nfps yeah
oh that's funny so wait does he actually
sell nft courses
i thought that's his whole business
model doesn't he sell like i don't know
because he makes so much from these v
friends he he's like i mean
i don't know he's pivoted what is the
con like what is that everybody's at
right now isn't aren't you supposed to
like learn from him isn't i mean isn't
that effective but i think it's being
sold he has he has a really
sophisticated
funnel now where he doesn't even need to
charge people for his videos he just
needs to get them in his cult
to convince them to buy his [ __ ] v
friends
yeah he was just talking about how to
buy like crypto so that's just bringing
more people into the crypto market to
buy his [ __ ] yeah because like at this
point he's making so much from v friends
he's probably made a hundred million
dollars from that [ __ ] i'm not even
exaggerating
that he doesn't need to sell courses
because because you know selling courses
probably doesn't even make him as much
money as that [ __ ]
and it allows you to be more skeptical
of his motivations here he can just be
like oh no it's all good dude i just
want people to learn about crypto and
learn about web three
when we start calling it web 3 dude
it's like a year ago
that's like the term's been around for
longer than that but about a year ago
almost overnight everybody
who
i guess started to realize that the well
was being poisoned by terms like crypto
a little bit uh
realized if we call it web 3 then that
doesn't have the negative association
with it whenever i hear someone say web
3 i'm like oh man they're they're gone
[Music]
you
know gone gone gone
let me give you a really good
hypothesis
for this conference
hypothesis you've probably decided which
panels you want to go with
or considering
many of you are going to choose based on
the person and you think they're cool
or
the subject matter is something you
already know and like
please challenge yourself to go to two
three
five twenty five fifty percent of the
panels
where you know nothing about it
where you're not sure about it this is
not a hypothesis in any way shape or
form is the time to triple down on
education in web 3.
[Music]
i don't know what education a web 3 even
[ __ ] means bro it's not that
complicated
holy [ __ ] what am i going to learn about
how to nft a house you know what i mean
that was a thing that he was suggesting
yeah i know so like okay
all right uh we got a we got an ad we
got to do
okay
i was holding off until we talked about
something other than
johnny depp all right let's just we have
only one sponsor to thank so stand by
and it's one of the greatest sponsors of
all time it's honey
today's episode sponsored by honey the
easy way to save when shopping on your
iphone or computer
yeah baby i love honey
ela she does most of the online shopping
she has saved
hundreds
possibly thousands of dollars i mean
how it works is you just go to the
checkout like normal when you have this
plugin installed
it automatically
applies the best coupon code it can find
on the internet at checkout it's
freaking magic and it feels amazing
because you don't expect it
i mean here's one for 186 bucks
i don't know what ela bought
table furniture or something
you're like okay i'm i'm ready to pay
the full price
boom ten percent 100 200 bucks
at checkout's insane
thanks to honey
manually searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past it's free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best one
it finds
um all you got to do is hit apply coupon
when the drop down comes down at
checkout
and bada bing bada boom bob's your uncle
you know what i'm saying
um
so it works on pretty much every
internet
well most you talk about clothing does
it work at web3
web 3 it hasn't been implemented on web3
yet as far as i'm aware we haven't made
that innovation garyvee
counts on v friends
no that's a joke but fashion tech food
even
you know
amazon
so yeah
it's amazing honey doesn't just work on
desktops anymore it also works on your
iphone just activate it on safari on
your phone and save on the go if you
don't already have honey you're straight
up missing out
and by getting it you'll be helping
yourself and helping us so when when
i use honey all the time i love it i bet
all my browsers get honey for free at
joinhoney.com h3tv that's join honey.com
h3tv thank you thank you all right
[Music]
all right let me watch
we should just watch emily's you're
right
i'm curious what her commentary looks
like
like how do you not just sit quietly and
watch it that's that's i mean
you know
like love you've watched it what does
like azmin gold talk about when he
watches it
uh he just reacts harder like he just
says random words like whoa
he really does that
all right let's go really
yeah and then he he'll say when
something cool happens
when something cool happens you say oh i
gotta talk about this in the break
oh my god he doesn't he never pauses he
just lets her hide yeah never post never
oh that's crazy
yeah dude
it's i i've been entertained by his live
stream so i'm not gonna lie so what am i
doing wrong what do i need to switch up
about it
i mean i'm i've been telling you react
harder dude
okay have you been doing it since the
beginning
you have to actually like know what's
going on he he's actually
he's he doesn't even
he doesn't know what's going on well he
said during the talk during the break
okay does he talk about it during the
break let me guess does he constantly
ask everyone around him in chat who's
this what's what are they talking about
well i'm i i shouldn't even ask
questions i just need to silently
just be like it all right good nuts can
ever let's try for
two minutes let's see if our views go up
and everybody react really hard just
everybody be really engaged with the
content okay
all right just just like reacting to it
no you don't
we don't ask questions right okay here
we go
okay guys let's get those views going
your clients are never oh my god it
exceeds two million dollars correct
incorrect
in the aquaman just isn't it it's
actually the justice league contract
because they're associated with justice
league justice league oh that movie
oh wow
absolutely
okay
let's put it differently your clients
what are you drinking two million
dollars for a movie stop asking
questions
drinking water dude you see that look
wait she
you need
i assume that you're referring to
pirates 5 it performed well at the box
office yes yes certainly not in
comparison to the other ones and that's
what a student doesn't even look at to
say
has that franchise had its run
or do we need to studio like disney
wants to walk away from an eighth oh
thereafter and with the increasing cost
and not only mr deputy we read into her
just making and marketing the film nuts
that's crazy 795 million dollars is a
lot of money yeah and it seems like a
really good box office but you have to
put into perspective of what's spent on
production right marketing and the
overhead cost that the studio takes so
you have again it's all in context
that's crazy that's so much money the
film and the marketing of the film is
all right let's put some more things in
context yeah okay here we go here we go
here we go here we go yes all right
she's um
most recently i guess in deep water with
ben affleck uh-oh deep water it was
better i don't again i know something
there we go
here we go here we go here we go aquaman
yeah
um
she was in the last james bond movie yes
she was yeah they were talking about
making her oh [ __ ] oh here's
right right after her big star of moment
star's born moment yeah she's gotten a
lot more here we go big roles which is
what we had from his hurt
yeah um
and she said that her breakout role was
blade runner interesting
it was it was like the first big you
know studio movie that got a lot of
attention i believe that was the one
that we can look at as a as a marker for
her sure right so true
that's true
i feel the same way i did
she watched
it was years ago i don't remember
exactly she doesn't remember she doesn't
blade runner idiot idiot it was such a
good movie too [ __ ] idiot
hold her in contempt of court since
it's a gigantic naked billboard
that was her role
are you saying that's the only thing she
was she was a gigantic naked billboard
she wasn't that's the principal role in
that movie i i don't i don't remember
the movie well enough to know what wait
that was her what not her wasn't that a
different actor yes did you know that
whatever talk a little bit about ben
affleck wait what right
rare l for johnny depp's legal team he's
an interesting example it's going up you
guys
he's been in a role
that's been recast
multiple times
multiple times
at least twice
maybe more
minimum minimum here we go here we go
here we go the title character in that
dc series
has seen how many actors
several
so that's not precisely several we need
to proceed
oh we got to talk about this in the
break guys okay okay hold on yeah okay
i'll put it i know what they're doing
now i know what they're doing okay okay
christian bale was batman yeah and i
think he was you're right
man definitely yeah
she likes to george gary oldman was
tiptoed
but you're taking an absolutely iconic
role
oh he's about he's all about it now
recast here we go five six times correct
correct so the just because you have the
role in the first movie or the second
movie
32 000 damage the belt
bring the bell down
i don't remember
here we go unless it's contractual
so
now
let's look um
oh
here we go
this is where they're gonna do it he's
got something up his sleeve guys yeah
yeah yeah just wait
watch watch probably even a bigger
breakout role for her but again i chose
blade running because it's a similar
thing you have to start somewhere but
right now probably was her big moment in
time she said you're wrong
she doesn't even know what she's talking
about
the other person you picked was chris
pine
uh chris pine is in a superhero
chris pine wonderful chris pine
everybody knows here we
here we go
star trek being a blockbuster but not
necessarily here we go
let's go here we go here we go
here we go uh yes he plays the love
interest to galata down yeah yeah um
on star trek in in the star trek
franchise
he plays captain kirk
okay
that's correct i don't remember exactly
oh stop that he played i didn't see you
you know damn well
do you know who captain kirk is oh yes
it is
well
but you didn't character she's squirming
is captain kirk in star trek
i hate to say i'm not a star trek fan
yeah well you're a
professional likely story example
irrespective of the fact you didn't even
know he starred
in this franchise film she's eviscerated
that's why he used it again
he's destroying her credibility right
now over this a couple more times and
i'm happy to do so all i wanted to do
was look at from a small pool of people
that have been in huge franchise movies
or
superhero movies
and and give you a sense of what the
range is or what summon trajectory can
be again they're they they're not apples
and apples they're not both green apples
they're both red apples i just was
looking at a range it's what we do we
get some red apples in chat they're kind
of like tomatoes it's what you do yeah
apple's a chat here we go get a sense of
how much you're going to pay an actor
what they're worth in the foreign
markets and the domestic
which is what this conversation is about
and again i chose him because he was
part of star trek and wonder woman
oh that's why people are voting yeah you
talked about breakout roles but you
don't know which which
here we go here we go here we go i love
these redditors he's been an actor he's
been a well-liked apples
star trek and in
wonder woman and star
she hasn't had the chance to negotiate
that for that yet or be in those movies
yet so we don't know yet we're getting
back to precipice didn't you just deny
this a few minutes ago i said
i thought your testimony was she was on
the precipice of meteoric rise you said
i guess
i i didn't say meteoric i said
consistent i don't know she could have a
meteoric rise
this is an important distinction right
here yeah meteoric like crashing into
earth
i think this could make or break the
case hold on here it comes two of them
are the title characters in their dc
right right right right right
one
one is aquaman who's the other title
character right gail goodell wonder
woman are you even paying attention
you're a woman and oh and you mean jason
i'm not sure yeah
yeah
so you get two title characters
you got
james kirk
and those are the people that you're
just
[Laughter]
so who's your favorite captain do you
think
oh i don't know i guess i don't really
like star trek you don't like star trek
movies okay hold on it went up a bit
dance stop it was a big movie
guys here we go here we go here we go
those are the actors i chose yes
and to show what type of work happens
when you're in a big movie and we get
some blueberries
or franchise movies that did very very
well the box office and there are tons
of actors and actresses who are in
superhero movies that don't have
meteorology right right right right
that's true yeah
the lead character with jason mamoa but
to your point there are many how
so you don't always just look at the
pass
anyone that does a movie with jason
momoa meteorized
so that happens in our business it just
does
our business
all right
with respect to your
comparable actors
you
have no personal knowledge
as to how much any of them were
compensated
over the period you reviewed incorrect
this is a big reveal
personal knowledge
jason
[Music]
and you derive that personal knowledge
from talking to somebody yes he didn't
tell okay
his agent did okay
what you will rely on what mr momoa's
agent told you but you have no no you
didn't see the contract right right
no his agent is at william morris as
well so they told me that seems credible
right yeah and you've never seen anybody
else's contracts as to what they were
making
no but in 25 years of being in this
business i understand the basis of which
actors are paid when they're in
blockbuster films and then they're in
large budgeted studio films
it's it's not a leap to kind of
understand where where the actors make
it again yeah it makes sense i really
didn't want to try to be sort of
in my analysis i wanted to work with the
numbers that amber had contracted for
already and just take it from there and
said if she had done one movie a year
and one series so she's saying she can
read a crystal ball and predict how much
money she's going to
make take her out it's wild right i
wasn't looking
next she's going to be offering 20
uh return on crypto
moa i took her numbers that her agents
had actually negotiated and worked from
there
when you say you weren't
trying to give her the same career as
jason mama
the
the tv
program that she most recently did the
stand
okay
honestly what are they even talking
about
no no no this is big right here
how are you going to compare her career
to jason momoa had an incredible career
you know starting with game of thrones
what has amber heard done she's famous
for [ __ ] in a bed okay take this out
you are giving her the same career as
jason malmo well again with someone like
uh
ms hurd who is in a blockbuster film
with the team at william morris in my
discussions with william morris that's
what they were looking to negotiate for
her on other projects so i got some of
that information from her management
team directly okay so her agents were
looking to get her as much money as
possible
that's the job that's the job of an
asian thing
yeah that was good
they were looking to
and what the prices that all the
streamers are paying these days
you haven't seen a single one of the
endorsement contracts that you
referenced other than miss herds no
other than again what i was talking i
was talking to william morris in terms
of the pricing that they are aware of
not only for their own clients but
what's out in the marketplace and it's
pretty consistent and i've also worked
with other actors on other cases that
have gotten similar contracts so i'm
familiar with the rates of endorsement
contracts right right right you haven't
made any reference to the actual
earnings of any of these actors
again as you do an analysis you put
together the numbers that you know from
both your experience and the marketplace
and the agents that are working in the
marketplace so together that's how i
created those numbers right and mostly
using miss herds numbers specifically
and giving her a very steady career
which is what she had had prior to
uh aquaman the [ __ ] in the bed yeah and
you don't have the prior earnings of any
of the actors you looked at other than
ms hurts
i don't have all the contracts now right
right
i'm sorry you don't have any of that she
didn't have any contracts okay
how can she promise the same career she
doesn't even know how much they make
yeah i don't understand what her job her
job is just focus focus dude it's
confidential yeah
usually it is yes yeah but and the only
reason just thinking about that first
guy's gatorade
yeah what was he doing
well you guys want to pipe in some brand
noise and see if the views go up i'm not
currently working as an agent who's got
the brown noise
no
uh i can i can whip something up
thank you don
hold
on okay
so very dead brown noise that's all the
salaries of these comparable actors
switch it up
i'm sorry but amber heard is not jason
momoa basis for your opinion that's the
point that she's making dude are you
even paying attention so no she's saying
that amber's lost a bunch of business
because of this that her career was
going to take off like jason no and i'm
saying she was never going to be jason
momoa
that dude's got a whole career she did
one stupid aquaman like that movie sucks
standard in the industry as well as
people like that with her whatever you
know
yeah that one did well do you know that
that was an airplane movie for me and i
hated it i don't know if it's standard
at any of the studios but it is standard
for agents to renegotiate and oftentimes
i'm trying to think of something what
you're talking about is there's an
existing contract
where miss heard his name
a promise that she will do the next move
jungle sound
no i want brownies
i want brown noise
and
you know what
the agent
than your contract says
because
you like her yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
well as mrs
said also people stay for the brown
they come for the title they stay for
the brown noise i've worked with agents
and i've worked with lots of lawyers and
you know we have conversations about
what is an actor getting or what can
they do or what are they going to do the
next time so again it's a standard
practice in the industry especially when
a film is as successful as aquaman that
the agents will go back and renegotiate
uh in fact that was conversation
standard practices that they were trying
coming up on 34k
studio i see
the movie
nature of aquaman they're very
successful it's almost there it's almost
the entirety of your analysis
assumes a renegotiation
with a studio for terms that are double
she's boring though
she's boring she would work for
correct next
i would do some cult 2018 courtroom too
just to liven it up
seriously
can we skip over the hard drink she took
can we skip her testimony
who is it he's a senior executive at
warner brothers or yeah we put down two
times there but certainly
at the time of the movie happening live
no i don't know where it works
trust me it works dc based film
productions i think that's exactly
it's a glitch in the matrix it does
i told you this doesn't make sense
i
did you understand all right we gotta
come back to her because [ __ ] shit's
boring
it's so it was a good run though
the views didn't really go up maybe a
little bit
should we just keep the brown noise
going chad said keep play the brown
noise you cowards it's on
the brown noise is playing explain
all right um let's get back to garyvee i
was actually enjoying that
i'm like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] who cares about this [ __ ] bro
it's so stupid
you know
uh where's garyvee's [ __ ]
my name's garyvee and i'm and i make out
with my dad
some of the crowd pulling a one-on-one
garyvee trading card and losing their
mind i was wondering what's going on
this guy you can kill the brown noise
it's getting kind of weird
although it is relaxing
let's do a pull keep the brown noise or
or
just said i feel like i'm in a plane
yeah
but a nice one it's not too loud
first class
um
you guys the we should probably get rid
of the brown noise
i can't imagine any value to keeping in
a constant noise usually people try to
another caller
people saying louder here's a good
question uh can dan take ecstasy for a
segment
oh my god
that'd be interesting what is the
segment
it sounds like a fun segment
sounds like dan takes ecstasy yeah you
take it then we find out what it is we
just put you in we put you in a room you
can't escape and ask you questions all
right that sounds like fun i'm done
all right let's move on
uh garyvee so so he has trading cards
too like what the [ __ ] is this
why does
does anyone have intel on what the [ __ ]
we have trading cards
right
that's true just saying i should have
signed one of them so this is at garyvee
convention
you're stressed out
[Applause]
does anyone know what just happened
uh cult
bunch of [ __ ] idiots got around
is that like a rare pokemon or something
well done
hold on hold the phone hold the phone
hold the [ __ ] phone
garyvee auto
v friends psa 10
a 10 out of 10. is that a real signature
yeah you really these people
are paying for this bro
look at this guy
that's the face he made in his big how's
he making that face it's the face he
made right before he kissed his dad
right right right interesting
scammed
i can't get i can't get over this view
friendship guys it's too much for me
here's another one
yeah so so it's a tr so he's got a whole
wow okay what the [ __ ] so he's got a
whole
box
of gary vee trading cards
sealed unopened oh wow so what is it
just all the v friends no that wasn't
from 2018 he teamed up with tops
what's on the cards just pictures of him
probably
wait it's only 200 bucks we should buy
it
yeah you should buy that ethan
uh it's not even for me for the gag i
can't do it oh here's here i can buy one
for 20 bucks on his
on oh they're sold out
so i missed it so wait what is on these
cards baseball
say
what it's just plagiarized content he's
a baseball player
was gary vee a pro baseball player
before he got into griffin that was not
him i look closely he's a pro in the
metaverse
um
there's more
crowd gets super excited for live
musical act
[Music]
she's
[Music]
the music needs to be about jesus like
all the music needs to be about nfts
like the [ __ ]
took the wind out of me i just like
stopped
[Music]
that was so fire dude
that's actually worth the ticket when
you realize how good the
live performances
oh the band is called crypto boy
crypto boy live performance of v con
hell yeah let's look up chris oh so this
guy is singing along this guy who filmed
it nft videos daily on youtube 31
subscribers shout out
whoa
we should have sent someone to v con man
next year
that'd be fun
get someone boots on the ground you know
he'll have already moved to curacao by
then
he invited gary v impersonators to come
hey everyone my name is gary vaynerchuk
series two i just wanna say if someone's
[ __ ] gratitude okay i'm just so
[ __ ] happy to be the only real
authentic garyvee like check one two
hold on one second [ __ ] i'm gary v
series three who the [ __ ] are you dick
wait so bro like i'm not the only gary
vee
nope bro like i have a [ __ ] question
for you man do you [ __ ] with blueberries
yup yup love it love it lovely [ __ ] you
buy your nails can i get a hit of that
yeah for sure until real [ __ ] [ __ ]
delicious do you wash your hands do i
wash my hands nope never yeah
this guy sucks this guy doesn't even
sound like him this guy actually is a
good impression
this dude is not even [ __ ] trying to
sound like him between the two of us
we're amazing it's almost like who needs
the original garyvee right
yo daddy
where the [ __ ] are you i'm the [ __ ]
series one [ __ ] series one [ __ ] i love
that [ __ ] but i'm sorry but this is all
just ego [ __ ] like come on bro
it's psychotic dude it is he's just
trying to prove how he's in on the joke
and then he comes out arm series one
[ __ ]
let's go own you
uh
i own you impersonators what's instagram
like
this
[Applause]
come on let's step up we can beat them
you're small the mighty
guys that are much smaller than you come
on
[Applause]
okay guys don't worry just step it up
hardco go very hard
guys they're so much smaller than you
and mike crazer is he's showing the same
picture every time his face looks insane
they're much smaller let's [ __ ] kill
them
[Applause]
oh that is different
guys i can't do this i can't do it i
[ __ ] hate him i don't care
i hate him
okay
thank you i'd rather watch this
bro this episode is just dog [ __ ] bro
we're not even trying to do anything
this episode this is the worst episode
ever nobody's here
you know everyone's
got the council going on yeah we had
such a great episode planned we really
did
it's true the olympia comeback stuff i'm
excited for wednesday it was great
and now that's right
i'm blaming amber heard for this if can
i blame her
absolutely man i can't [ __ ] stand her
she's she's done this to us coke
snorting [ __ ] lying
go on
i i'm gonna get don't go too far i'm
gonna get canceled go on by the amber
just saying
nobody supports amber
the only people that support amber are
toilet paper companies although they
didn't like her anyway because she don't
wipe her ass use sheets
what we need to do is unlist this
episode
and then release it like three days late
and say the deleted episode
this is what the tr the frenemies
deleted episode yeah so we'll get a some
clickbait views
um there was a few other things at the
top i wanted to talk about namely
that kanye west's boots keep getting
bigger
and i love the oh my god bro we got to
show this to ela
dude what are those
boots with laces
those are some what's happening here
balenciagas
they look like cartoon boots
clown shoes for
damn boot
oh this boot craze is nuts
he looks like he's wearing toilet
plungers
[Laughter]
dude those boots are off the rails oh
yeah
oh in the dark okay i like the dark shot
why not
it's not like i can [ __ ] see anything
compared to the yeezys from a few months
ago i feel like i like these better
yeah these are better than those like
weird
yeah alien looking shoes that he was
trying to but i mean they're still bad
these these are nuts dude
these are wild wild shoes um i'ma just
want a new witness this lady is boring
bro she's so boring
aquaman this
jason momoa that
james charles
uh another one
let's see
wait
i think i didn't this kid
didn't this kid get exposed for lying
something
didn't james make a response
let's see
here james posted a video of himself
i could clear you up a bit wait is this
the video james posted james responded
yeah the kid just showed the first part
where it showed that james responded to
his story and then james showed the
context showing the messages
showing that the kid wanted a sugar
daddy basically
i think he should take him up i don't
think he has many other offers
james is
okay whatever who cares
oh
[ __ ]
what else
elon musk acknowledged the a3 podcast
yes so jackson the guy who uh the
inventor of dogecoin
uh his partner he has a co-founder
who tweeted graciously tweeted out the
interview
he said catch my co-founder jackson the
one who people keep mistaking for me in
articles on the h3 podcast talking about
crypto silliness and his new podcast
i recommend listening to jackson about
crypto even if you don't fully agree he
has a lot of experience and perspective
that's that's nice that's a nice respect
why is this guy this guy's actually like
pretty big
um 1.5 million followers
creator of dogecoin
that's nuts shiba tashi nakamoto
it's a play on the
suit the pseudonym of the guy who
invented bitcoin
is he associated with the shib shibi
coin
no it's just like or maybe maybe he is i
don't
i don't know well damn that's that's
pretty incredible there you go buddy but
anyway elon musk responded he can be a
little negative at times to be honest
i mean dude what
how [ __ ] dare you talk about first of
all jackson my homie
and second of all
he basically is watching this show right
now i think we can pretty much confirm
elon is a fan
um
i think we we can we can draw that
conclusion from this no
yeah
elon if you're watching gift a billion
subs
if you're watching about amber heard
elon if you're watching tweet something
stupid tonight
oh yeah good call oh
yeah we'll see
we'll see if he uh comes through
that's a good test
so there you go elon's a fan
clearly
you know
[ __ ] interesting in it it's really
just saying so interesting
uh we got the quartering
oh i wanted to talk about the modern
philosophy thing but we should hold that
i wanted to have a discussion with you
guys about if one fruit or vegetable
disappeared from existence which one
would have the biggest impact on
humanity or earth just in general i have
some good ones fruit or vegetables but
don't answer it yet i want to wait until
everyone's here maybe one
where did this come from i was just
thinking about it
there i was using one particular product
and i thought this one product is so
versatile it's in everything like
imagine if it just disappeared that'd be
so crazy and then i thought like well
which
is there anything else that would have
such a big impact if it disappeared you
know
i mean there's one that
actually there's two that come to mind
immediately that would be
but i guess we're safe i have a really
good answer
it's the one that i was using
oh and by the way also dan why are we
saving it why don't we just because i
don't know there's just it's not now
it's not the time this is a throwaway
episode right let's not waste good
content on this [ __ ] okay that's a good
point save it for another [ __ ]
episode maybe on
wednesday or friday you know okay that's
true that's a good point for craig's
sake this is just a [ __ ] dumpster
fire
of an episode unwatchable we should name
this podcast uh this podcast is getting
deleted within 48 hours that's that's a
good idea now we're talking yeah
now we're cooking parentheses it's the
worst episode
the worst episode of the history podcast
how's that inspired by abe
because i said because he said something
before i said something similar oh i
want to start eating cheetos guys
nothing going to stop me from making
this episode dog [ __ ]
let's make it as bad as possible at this
point
you want to choose cheetos
i'm just hungry i didn't eat breakfast
you know
i should eat breakfast
i didn't i just i woke up and i just
wasn't really feeling hungry you get
that sometimes yeah like i looked at
what was in the fridge and i was like
i can't do it huh
you're like nah dog
we have quartering updates
uh he had some tweets about funneling
his
dad's balls or something like that
oh yeah oh wait did we not talk about
where we did we never talked about him
fondling his dad's balls
wait okay
we talked about when his dad wants okay
here let's read uh discussion with the
wife as she watched our father
one of the women found out it was her
father we never talked about this
no
not on leftovers we had it in the dark
we just didn't get to it yeah oh this is
so good
we didn't get to it
the quartering as you know he defecates
in his own basement and stomps it down
with his feet he's an absolute beast he
talks a lot of [ __ ] he is the face of
white purity
i can't get over the white supremacists
just look at them they're such [ __ ]
inbred freaks who wants to live in a
country with people that look like that
like look at the quartering and i'm sure
that and like i'm
i don't think quartering has ever
explicitly come out as being a white
supremacist but he talks about
replacement theory and stuff right
oh jesus not not i don't want to see
drawing i just like quartering just
people being tortured which is not
unlike watching a show but
jeremy
yeah
dude his last name's hambly dude dude
looks like a ham this is the face of
white supremacy do you know what i mean
like
these guys talk about racial purity it's
like dude what are you trying what's
if you want to make your genes pure at
least look good you know start with
something better than this
like if you're trying to breed um
if you're trying to breed like the
perfect yorkshire terrier you don't
start with like a [ __ ] up freak ass
mutant do you want a beautiful dog right
like if you want i'm just saying if you
want a perfect white race start with
something better than this
does anyone does anyone
cosign
like look at this what that looks like a
dog for sure logic
ian
that's true of all white supremacists
you know did you just at least hit when
hitler was doing geogenics you would get
like perfect swedish beautiful women
right wasn't he doing that to like mate
with germans it's like you don't start
with this bro i'm just saying thank you
next go ahead just
ian just kind of like did he die he
looks
like he's happening
ian are you sitting there
hold on ian
come back
i think ian killed over no he's like
scooting around or something he went
exercising he went like driving by the
frame oh is he rolling around in his i
think so
he's trying to hit 10 000
[Music]
this is the face of uh
white eugenics
we need to we need we need racial purity
guys
like seriously if you type uh
let's type uh white supremacists i just
can't get over
how [ __ ] ugly these people are
look at this this i'm saying bro we
don't start with something better
you know what i mean
i just don't start
yeah
well
yeah i mean obvi you know eugenics bad
right
but i'm just trying to give them some
feedback now i don't believe in eugenics
obviously
or racial supremacy of any kind
i think we're all god's children
but if you want a white master race
you've got to start with something
better than this
because these are all dumb [ __ ]
sweaty pig
you're trying to if you want to do a
a cross between a pig and a human
that's an interesting
combination if you want to try to [ __ ] a
pit if you want to create a human that
looks like a pig that's good
man bear pig you know like a like a
skinless cat if you want to breed some a
human that looks like a skinless pet pig
skinless cat or i mean a hairless cat
you know have there's something that
don't have hair
yeah yeah no i know that this is like a
pig bro this snake you don't gotta
insult hairless cats i love hairline
i just saying they you can really i love
skinless cats
you can really
you can really breed specific uh trades
some guys are less thin if you want if
you want to breed a perfect white race
that lives in a [ __ ] stable and eats
out of a sloth bucket start with this
right right
i mean again for sure
ain't being ready amen brother
but anyway i'm talking about the
quartering of course
yeah who i don't even know
if he espouses uh google uh replacement
theory and quartering i'm pretty sure
he's been there okay
yeah i'm pretty sure he does
can you imagine though
you could breed those people into
[ __ ]
you could breed those people into a
whole new species
it's awesome
um
[Applause]
anyway the quartering said
discussion with my wife as she watches
our father
one of the women found out it was her
father
who was actually her ob gyn
my wife was grossed out
i was like actually if someone is
handling my sac
or doing a prostate exam
i prefer it was my dad
who agrees thoughts let's get that let's
get the conversation going
i watched our father because
i don't know if you guys remember but
i actually had a fear of this because um
bruce was
are not artificially insanity but
they took my sperm
and put it in ila impregnated her that
way
turkey-basted her i like to say is the
medical
uh procedure and um
i was like dude i won't do that because
the doctor is gonna squirt and put his
own semen in because i know so this is
the guy that actually does this this is
documentary
it's really interesting on hbo really
disturbing though
he was a
fertility doctor
and he was
using his own sperm
for people women who were looking for
donors
and he was doing ones where he would
throw out the father's sperm and use his
own jizz so he would go back jerk off
into a cup and then bring it in and put
it i mean it's [ __ ] the man is vile
also he was never charged which is the
most [ __ ] up thing like in my opinion
i think he he r-worded every woman he
did that to
and the piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] district
attorney
refused to charge him so the guy never
even really faced any consequence oh
it's on hbo okay or netflix netflix
netflix
it's on hbo
no people are saying netflix
i think there's two two different
documentaries about the oh about the
same guy
well the one our father i watched on
netflix
but anyway
the fact that his wife is like recoiling
a [ __ ] from this horrific
horrific disgusting freak and he's like
actually that's kind of dope
um so
yeah basically this woman thought her
biological dad was her dad
and actually it was this disgusting
[ __ ] freak of a human being
who used his own semen
and uh
hundreds and hundreds of times by the
way
and
so he says my wife was grossed out by
that
but i actually thought that was pretty
dope
who agrees thoughts
yeah i mean i would prefer a doctor to
fondle my sack and prostate not my dad
again i don't know the relationship
quartering has with his dad clearly more
comfortable than mine well
he's uh
adopted he has he's
he was raised by two black gay dads
actually okay what's that have to do
with anything i'm just saying that was
maybe they both fingers [ __ ] that's
what he told us
[Laughter]
maybe both dads get in there
one nut for each dad
two fingers one butthole
that sounds like a good time to be
honest
um
this may be a fundamental difference
between men and women which i totally
understand either that or need therapy
yeah the last one big time
i like how he carves that out like well
that's unlikely
no you need therapy bro
you need a new brain therapy's not gonna
cut it you need a brain transplant
it was accurately pointed out below that
it would be more of a fair comparison to
find out that my bald doctor was in fact
my mom
not my dad to be fair that does change
things
so he's evolving i mean they're both
growing he's always learning
i don't want either of my parents
grabbing my balls man yeah
you know what i mean
so this is the this is the great mind of
the quartering i just want to know what
kind of mindset he was in when he was
like oh this is a good idea drunk
that's true that's true
he's an alcoholic
he went looking for affirmation like to
prove to his wife that this is a common
thing that people
think too like he's looking for people
to agree with him
so she was probably like why am i with
you again yeah he's like i'm not crazy
let me ask twitter
wait we did oh so this was a different
one we were talking about
how oh my god this guy is like
does more gaffes than joe biden
[Music]
we talked about this previously he says
my wife had an emergency landing and
caught a ride with another pilot
to go to the hangar
female pilot privilege
the moral of the story is i don't have
to go pick her up and i get to play more
video games and we're like dude your
wife is getting railed right now
by that pilot there's no question about
it
let's go
um
and he responded to me
[Music]
by saying
dear ethan it's called a joke remember
those maybe stick to hemorrhaging
subscribers
and running
the world's only clothing line designed
exclusively
for pedos
now the heming subscribers thing's true
i will stick to that
definitely can see that but
the clothing line made for pedos i
thought was a weird very weird very
specific
insult
and so
you know if you really look into it
if you want if and i say well i don't
know any petals that wear
teddy fresh
but when the more i thought about jeremy
uh the more i thought well this is
[ __ ]
really interesting because
i started thinking well
jeremy's first channel
was going
around arcade games
and i mean well just look at them right
i mean
if you go sit in the red light district
in thailand you'll see basically like
what's going on arcade games it was claw
machines with little stuffed animals for
kids
so yeah yeah exactly this was his first
uh
passion
hey there i'm jeremy and you've come to
that part of youtube where you might be
wondering how the heck you got here
together with my beautiful wife and our
best friend brandon we're about as
obsessed with the arcade as anyone
specifically claw machines now is that a
normal uh no i just i'm only bringing
this up because he accused me of running
a clothing brand for for pedos
now i'm just saying like
in terms of hobbies for a grown-ass man
that looks like this
i'm just not sure that going and playing
claw games is necessarily the best
optics you know what i mean
yeah that seems look at this face is
that the face of someone you want to
play a claw machine with when you're
eight
i travel the country playing claw
machines with all the kids that
want running by themselves let's watch
different machines that have them in our
houses
at home it's like he's making this for
kids wow that's so cool you guys want to
come play claw machines with me we
record our journeys as we travel across
the country trying to win as many prizes
as humanly possible we'll also show you
how these machines work
and how to win and while we're not
clawing we're going to show you how to
win massive tickets at a totally
different arcade no oh hell yeah i love
candy
you know who loves candy more than
anything in the world my three-year-old
son
candy is life to him
[Music]
so you know again i'm not listen i'm not
i'm just saying
because you said the clothing is kind of
like for p words it just got me thinking
is all you need another reason to
subscribe we also do giveaways we'll
ship the prizes no way give me your ass
just give me your address dude yeah
exactly no way
this is so cool this guy is awesome and
he gives away candy and prizes
dude see us winning on this channel
we're probably going to give it away go
ahead become part of the claw struck
crew and get notified each and every
time we upload a new super fun video by
crushing that subscribe button today
yeah so
i'm just saying that
and then you know
um
there's actually other things like this
tweet here
okay now i'm just again i'm not i'm not
saying anything
maybe i'm just saying it takes one to no
one
but i'm not one and the brand isn't one
so that that actually doesn't sound good
you know
i don't like that yeah that's a bad
angle i'll take that angle
i disavow that angle
whoever smelted dealt it maybe that's a
better angle
yeah
interesting never heard that applied to
p word accusations he says your clothing
brand is for p words i said well whoever
smelted dealt it my friend
watch this what is the age of consent
what should it be in your mind enjoy
this
i support whatever law is in place in
your current residence you know
it's cop-out doesn't it
let's get a real case asia argento right
easy
argento are you guys bearing you
familiar with this
she quote uh allegedly
groomed a
14 year old boy and then [ __ ] him when
he was 17. now
how old she
she was like almost 40 at that point
oh [ __ ] well she had also worked with
him when he was like a eight-year-old or
a nine-year-old boy in some hollywood
set why are we focused on that well no
i'm just i'm i'm just trying to take a
long i'm trying to it's a really long uh
example of how i feel well it's hard to
say like every 17 year old boy is
created equal right
but i'm saying like asia argento was
in her 40s she [ __ ] a 17 year old and
the age of consent in california is 18.
so she technically broke the law do i
view her as a [ __ ]
disgusting child predator no i don't
that will
in all seriousness though if she if she
groomed him from the from the time he
was 14 i i think it is a pretty pretty
disgusting crime if she was 40. i could
understand if she was 19 and he was 17.
i mean that's that happens but
um 40 and she's she's she's groomed him
since 14. now that's [ __ ]
up but isn't that [ __ ] up right like
if i'm 16 and let's say a 24 year old
woman you know i'm at some like
uh a music festival he's so he's trash
absolutely trash
it's really hard for me to view that as
like a predatory situation i'm like yeah
in the asa argento situation she
absolutely knew how old he was yeah she
and then like
i mean oh no no i wasn't talking about
i'm i was talking about your example
scenario oh yeah four year old chicken
if she if she knew that that guy was 16
yeah that's [ __ ] she's done she's
committed a crime
but if you're 16 and you get that [ __ ]
do you feel like a victim
did cool
i'm just saying it seems like he's doing
some mental he's jumping through some
mental hoops there and the fact that
he's like blackout drunk
you know
uh
is is you know he's got no filter there
which
but but uh i just sounds to me that a
man who travels the country playing claw
machines asking for kids addresses
and talking about how the age of consent
is too strict
there's a lot more than me
about uh
whatever p words want to buy or be or
whatever i'm just saying you know what i
mean just saying just saying do you
think he travels a country in a van
well of course he's got to bring lots of
stuff lots of candy he's got to you know
bring all of his video equipment it's
got to be a big white van right with no
windows because they probably sleep in
it too right so you don't want no
windows because also the equipment is
sensitive to light yeah you don't want
anybody peeping in
right right
and he probably has duct tape back there
you know
just in case because duct tape is useful
when you're on all trip rope is really
useful to have shovel you know zip ties
you know zip ties are good to have when
you're the quarter
just saying
you know
um
what is this
what is this maybe from
dr quincy
oh about the guy yeah
uh the only time quartering defended a
woman
is when she's a p word that's
interesting yeah he never really defends
women but the only time he came out to
unilaterally defend is when she was
accused of having sex with a minor and
grooming them from the age of eight no
that's not true actually there there is
one other time that he came out hard to
defend a woman go on
that uh chick that got fired from star
wars oh you're saying the vaccine is
gonna put a microchip in you or whatever
of course he loved her yeah he like
really loved her how is he still married
man it's so weird
i want to interview his wife that'd be
the [ __ ] conversation of a lifetime
in the role of a lifetime jeremy's wife
she's a pilot too
i know she's got like stuff going on for
her
and you're married to a man who
defecates in your house on the floor of
your
house and his hobbies are claw machines
i believe he peed and he peed and he
pooped in walmart yeah
see i thought he was pooping down you've
gotten confused by zach's brilliant edit
of combining those two stories he just
he just pees in the basement yeah yeah
in the basement drain he doesn't [ __ ]
down the base yeah
that we know of that we know that we
know we could speculate though you know
there's all speculation that he could
have a hole in the basement where he
does [ __ ] he definitely no i think he
shits on the great on the drain grate
and stomps it down
he waffles it yeah he stomps it down
so shout out to the quartering of course
friend of the show
good guy
he's an expert on uh
p words
and uh has credentials there in fact he
could be a star witness
i think if it ever came up in court you
know
so fascinating stuff
um
is anything what's going on in the
johnny depp anything interesting
johnny johnny
cheating sugar no papa telling lies no
papa open your mouth jeremy's coming in
it shines at a very bright light right
now the actors especially
this is this is from a while ago how is
she still talking she's not click the
live you're like way behind dude because
you paused it oh
well she might still be talking hashtag
okay um i just click live and it goes
live yeah dude in your review the
technology social media campaigns and
the negative social media it's so
eccentric
she's so boring
don't they understand it's not about her
it's about entertaining the people
they've got this trial backwards bro get
her off this stand
get johnny yes papa out there include
the wme that include mr schnell and just
that's boring why are you used to
watching turn off what if it's just
boring the [ __ ] episode i'll do
whatever [ __ ] i want
i'm about to play hangman or something
free to play
how good are you at minesweeper
i would say i'm like
okay not great i'm a [ __ ] minesweeper
god my dude i'm definitely not i'm
definitely not
really you think you're that good
[ __ ] god status really
pretty good of mine sweeper
that's cool that's a hard game i mean
it's hard it's challenging you know and
the defamatory start statements that
we're in nobody cares lady
can we see a game maybe
that'd be fun i'm doing like 15 things
here already today
okay
audio i got the [ __ ] switch i'm in
the chat right
we're very understaffed
um xqc responds to ludwig
saying he would never sell out for
gambling so is xqc now getting mad at
other streamers for saying they wouldn't
do it youtuber ludwig added his voice to
the debate claiming he wouldn't be
including any gambling in his content
oh he had a previous gambling addiction
interesting yeah so so was ludwig one of
the guys working
doing uh
sponsors with i don't believe so i think
he was referring to uh
off stream uh gambling addiction unless
love do you know anything about that oh
he he made a video
he made a video twitch needs to stop
gambling streamers so he's calling out
xqc and train wreck and all these guys
that's cool what is this mogul mail is
this like a second channel or something
yeah
i wonder why he posted there
i know i haven't really talked about it
much but it's true so when he films this
video did is this just a video for
youtube he didn't stream this right
yeah yeah yeah he usually does that five
years ago it got so bad i had 100 left
in my bank account and you know what i
did with that 100 i gambled it on a
mario party 4 minigame against slime
and lost
anyway good good for ludwig um that's
great
so let's see what xqc says
in response to that
xqc has a theory of why ludwig doesn't
have a price
okay
seriously dude that's that's the angle
um guys i did some mental uh
investigation about this game forty four
minutes says it doesn't have a price
then it then it hit me then it hit me
they named me
it's because ludwig is on youtube and
youtube doesn't allow any of it even a
little bit
and youtube and the idlebig
signed
and sold out to youtube
therefore he literally contractually
cannot in any way shape or form do it
now now i got it now it just kind of
clicked so so his theory is that anyone
would take the money
that's idiotic honestly
i'm sorry but xqc's [ __ ] lost the
plot dude
you know what i mean anyone i could get
a huge gambling uh
well i guess i don't know if i could
since i'm on youtube but i can do it on
twitch people watch me on twitch do it
i was arguing with these dudes in the
council the other day
because we were talking about the same
thing
and i said i wouldn't i wouldn't
like just play slots on stream for any
amount of money and they said i was a
[ __ ] capping
no i i
like you changed my mind i i was under
the impression that everyone had a prize
too i guess but then
i trust him and he said he wouldn't do
it for any kind of money yeah yeah i
believed you when you said so yeah
but i i definitely would do it for a
good chunk of money
but the thing is when you're in a
position to get that much money from
them you're already rich
true exactly you you as who you are now
they're not going to pay you millions of
dollars you already have to be rich
yeah that's at what point
the benefits and you know the everything
else
it becomes way less worth it
true
but it's kind of disgusting how he's
like
it's [ __ ] gross dude
yeah he has to desperately convince
himself that everyone else would be
doing this if they were getting paid
what he is
but that's not the case actually and uh
has he revealed yet gross what he's
being paid or is he keeping that close
to this i'm sure he's not telling [ __ ]
about that
he he's invested in convincing everyone
he gambles at all
you know what i mean to be guessing
based on the leaked aiding images
how much was adam getting paid 2 million
a month yeah
so i mean xqc is way bigger than way
bigger way bigger and he's held out for
a long time so the fact that he's
getting back on gambling has even more
kind of like meaning to them
okay
so
like if if aiden ross was getting two
million
i mean what's your aiden ross uh uh
average on a gambling stream do you know
love zero now because he got banned
wait wait aiden got banned off twitch
yeah aidan's gone it's been like a month
no way over a month
and is he on youtube or anything
i think he's just kind of like taking it
as an opportunity to dip for a while
right so
randomly yeah he's been gone for a while
but randomly i watched like keemstar's
story the other the other week i guess
and he said he said he had heard from
from
adam ross like the other day and said
that he's planning a comeback of some
sort so he might be signing to some
platform maybe
god that's so crazy
yeah
it seems
dropping that f slur remember yeah yeah
it seemed a little me it wasn't even on
his stream it was on someone else's
stream yeah but i mean it was obviously
him and i guess he had been he got in
trouble that was
you know
defense or something it's funny how
twitch is so strict but they let this
gambling [ __ ] ride that was what i was
saying the other day like
if you
[ __ ]
show too much cleavage
you know as a woman they'll they'll ban
you in a second but like you can just
like hawk gambling to children all day
long no [ __ ] problem showing cleavage
like bro
that has no negative effect on society i
mean well i guess you could write a
paper about it if you wanted
but like it's not worse than porn which
is readily available to anyone on twitch
gambling other than um
even pokemane
claims she wouldn't do twitch gambling
for any money
she got offered a hundred million
dollars no she's saying even if she was
offered 100 million she wouldn't take it
yeah i believe her
i mean she's wealthy
she's already wealthy
but
it's just
you have to live with yourself dude i
don't know what to say
listen i've had a lot of friends even
tell me
that they have a number right
is it three million a month is it five
is it oh yeah i was trying to guess what
what the xqc i wouldn't be surprised
guys if it was like
five to ten million a month i was
thinking 5005 yeah five to ten million
per month
it's a lot of that's a lot of cheddar
that you think they're paying drake oh
my god dude it's impossible to say
dude it's got to be a lot it's got to be
a lot
10 million a month i mean that's 100
million dollars in a year that's insane
bro
that just gives you an idea of how much
money they're making and crazy crypto
[ __ ] unregulated i don't even know
how they do their taxes like how do they
even account for all this [ __ ] right
god lee man
this house of cards is gonna come
tumbling down it's gonna be catastrophic
do you guys remember how much people
haven't
been gambling oh
yeah
yeah i remember he had like 20 to or he
had around 50k viewers xqc has 100k
yeah he's more yeah
a bunch
he must be making 10 but you know
compounded with the fact that xqc's the
highest earner on twitch for like years
running the guy is [ __ ] loaded
yeah
number
i'm really glad that ludd is ready to
say he doesn't have a price and same
here i don't have a price because if i
was making 5 million a month because you
guys were losing 5 million a month no
you would have to be losing way more
because steak would have to profit if
i'm making 5 million because i know my
viewers are losing 10 million
the guilt would eat me alive
genuinely speaking
cap yo tell steak to give me a hundred
million a month offer watch me decline
it
watch her accept it be like
no of course i believe her of course
uh
of course
um
is has this gambling
returned to gably kick back that excuse
you at all love has he kind of suffered
any consequence from this
no not really he i mean most of his fans
doesn't really care i mean i'm not
surprised by it oh yeah yeah
he's still doing the same stuff
oh juicing yeah it's amazing
but i think ultimately at the end of the
day there's gonna come a day when the
when the you know
chickens come home to roost on this one
uh i think he's gonna
he's gonna
he's gonna have to deal with this at
another time
but there's no good end to this whole
steak thing man it's nuts
yeah i think we talked about every
[ __ ] thing in this document
let's see
we have talked about every goddamn thing
of this document oh yeah
so let's just watch this [ __ ] april 2020
oh this is the best part
let's go all right so when is johnny
depp actually taking the stage
hopefully never
tomorrow probably
you know what guys this [ __ ] sucks bro i
can't even pretend like it's good it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] and it ruined this
episode and i'm pissed about it it's not
my fault it's amber hurt's fault
isn't it what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
dude yeah so let's change the title to
this episode will be erased in 24 hours
so but does that title stop being good
after 24 hours 48
yeah let's make it four days let's give
it a little more time 72 hours this
episode will be erased in 48 hours
parentheses the worst
stop right there stop stop why not
you want to write the worst episode no
yeah they got to come and see why it
will be deleted yeah
no so don't no don't write that okay all
right
jesus
come on man oh my god
so wait what's the current title this
episode will be a race i think 24 hours
is juicier though right it's 48 hours
like what two days so urgency
we can put one hour now and then after
one hour we change it to two and we just
keep keep increasing it one hour
yeah
the ship still be erased in 1
257 hours how did i've seen youtubers do
that like mr beast had a video where
he's like i've donated this one how did
they do that and they just keep updating
it yeah no but there's it does it in
real time
oh no i don't think it's real time bro i
swear to god
let me show you
they have some kind of program but if
you go mr beast this video donated
uh whatever money
oh it's so hard to find my understand
was that they just updated once per day
or something no dude you refresh it and
it updates
really that's cool
uh there was another guy science channel
he said this video has this many views
and updates in real time too
hmm
it's probably just a script yeah
whatever pretty cool though yeah look at
this one
this channel by the way this guy's
awesome i love his channel
the title of this video what
so it says this video has 53 million
whatever
let's see if it updates
bro come on dude update
wow you just got proven wrong on bro
[ __ ] all over your face bro oh
[ __ ] embarrassing dude
the title of this video won't be exactly
right it only updates every few minutes
at most and besides youtube doesn't
update its view counts in real time
anyway so don't bother refreshing and
refreshing and refreshing you won't
see it
second by second if it's actually 100
spot-on it's a miracle but
if it's close then the code i've written
is still working but at some point that
code will break and the title of this
video will slip more and more out of
touch with reality
all right so anyway let's refresh it
yep it have updated guys wow thank you
thank you
so we basically can anyone write a
script real fast
love can get on that
yeah i got it i got some script yeah
scripting you can do
yep
tom scott's awesome man
love those science bros
shout out soul life for gifting 10 subs
let's [ __ ] go right to the soul
let's go right now
um
this episode be racing 24 hours that
sounds good who's clicking that
jazz said feeling goofy might delete
later let's do a voting
no that one's not good
let's do it this episode will be a race
in 48 hours
or let's throw a wild card in there
wait what is the what's being asked
we're going to do a poll yeah
which is a better
title
this episode will be erased in 24 hours
it's too long let's throw in a wild card
which would be like
ethan farts on his hand and smells it
for four hours straight
so okay but would you click that would
you click that no
people are just gonna vote for that one
dan so let's cut that one out
oh we got get we got subbies
shout out oh sweet potatoes five shout
out
hannah
five gifted subs shut up maya
mad jane what's up welcome to super
trooper army
let's go
let's [ __ ] go
let's go
um
dan you got any suggestions
amber hurd versus johnny depp
final verdict
live my suggestion got shot down i said
that we should title it this is the
worst episode of the http okay
that that's fine
yeah yeah yeah yeah
all the
the the poll
character limit is not good for this all
of these titles are too long for the
poll so just abbreviate it people know
okay 24 hours is one of the options
worst episode ever ever
what are some other options here
quartering is a is a pedo confirmed 100
percent confirmed no i'm kidding don't
write down okay
dan takes nice
what the best episode ever no see
i can't even write that
i can't even write that can we call it
just um
four hours of brown noise
relax uh study sleep too
how about um johnny depp oh somebody
donated ten dollars and said austin
mcbroom stole my car
ooh
beardology i like that
maybe after the 24 hours title is like
up
you could change it to that so we're
just harvesting views and then switching
it up
absolutely
that's [ __ ] interesting pretty good
heard versus our patient i love that we
have to trick people into watching our
show
i mean we don't have to nobody would
watch this [ __ ] willingly we have to
[ __ ] drink them to click and hit
don't don't actually have to do that
amber heard uh ruined the a street
podcast that's true
i'm suing amber heard
there you go for damages i'm suing it
punitive damages
someone just said frenemy's reunion
that'd be that would definitely do well
the lost episode of framing you just
title it frenemy
i mean we've done clickbait that bad
before
no
uh honda gave us all coven
that one might be that is kind of a good
title too i guess
dr michael davis
olivia richardson olivia goated content
genius
johnny depp's lawyer calls in someone
suggested
lawyer calls yo that's juicy just try
that one that one could be [ __ ] fire
dude what about johnny depp's lawyer
calls in
ace mcbroom stole my car if user going
up with this episode will be a race in
24 hours
okay
okay
yeah i do think that's the best and then
after 24 hours we swap it to 48.
just keep sending it okay okay
sorry let's go with that let's go with
that
okay four hours of brown noise i see
people liking that
this video will be deleted in 24 hours
parentheses police and trisha paytas
involved
someone said johnny depp's lawyer 3 a.m
ouija board
someone said ian died
ian died of covet again how are you
doing ian you look sick as hell
um
you know jonah and the whale
yeah you ever heard of it
the biblical story
yes
what about it
what if the whale
is
life
i'm not familiar with that story
what it's the old testament what is the
story about
jonah he gets eaten by uh by a giant
whale but his faith in god allows him to
survive so it's pinocchio well pinocchio
came way after this is a biblical how do
you know
well they're printing bibles today see
the arrow of time moves from the past
they're still monkeys the president if
we're still having monkeys then how is
there humans how is there pinocchio
without henry and the whale
henry and the whale
yo they [ __ ] pinocchio straight
ripped that story
is that why jordan cries about it
yeah
well i mean yes actually isn't he
directly talk about that it's like he's
all about like archetypes and uh you
know the whale
i dreamed i saw my maternal dreams i saw
my grandmother's pubes it was like the
teeth of a whale what do you call it
whale teeth baleen yep baleen it had the
appearance of a thick matter it had the
appearance of a whale's baling
and she used it for much the same
purpose
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair
she used to sift through the sand with
her pubic hair like a fine comb
she was stroking herself absent-mindedly
my grandma was beating her [ __ ]
worn out nasty vag and told me to dive
right in her genital region was exposed
dimly
dimly exposed but in my mind's eye i
could see it brightly
[Music]
go ahead jordan
thought we were doing like a call and
answer
she walked over to me with a handful of
pubic hair
[Music]
and she said hey buckle i'd like to pay
for my food now
her genital region was exposed dimly
she let her have her way where's that
one
i dreamed i saw my maternal grandmother
sitting by the bank of the swimming pool
i let her have her appearance of a thick
mat of hair
i i pulled these on the fly that the
other one oh you're not ready you're not
prepared you're not prepared so anyway
ian what about the whale i'm with you
you're talking about pinocchio
he wasn't he was talking about jonah and
the whale so joan and the whale
okay
i was just saying that the
what if the whale is this mortal coil
okay
right
what about
in the belly of the beast
i feel fine
for now
[Music]
he seems to be having a hard time
you're struggling he's struggling a
little bit poor yeah
ex-essential dread is apparently a
culvert side effect they didn't know
that
[ __ ]
how long we've been going
way too long
what's that mean uh two hours and 40
minutes it feels like way too long we've
gone longer than this though that's what
i'm saying
maybe i'll get a snack and we can keep
going
this episode will be erased in 48 hours
buckle
you think really people are gonna click
that [ __ ] like
like okay bye
they'd be like good erase it
uh someone says can you take calls again
are you trying to [ __ ] ruin my life
dude
do you know what happened last time we
took calls
a [ __ ] like a third of the people
stopped watching the show because they
think i'm homophobic
johnny dumps back
thank you to everybody gifting subs
sweet potato i gave you a shout out
to wait two sweet potatoes no
hannah yeah i thanked you guys god bless
you
brandon schaub invited me into his car
call in from jordan peterson's grandma
that's shocking
so wait is actually is he back
no
what about dream he has got good titles
like minecraft speedrun
against 20
i don't know what he does something like
that
all right well
anything else we literally cleared the
dock but we i don't think the johnny
depp thing has much legs
i think that if we're live and something
interesting is happening
then we can watch it but this lady today
[ __ ] sucked dude she didn't even know
star trek
from star trek
uh and like literally so dumb dude
[ __ ]
all right lots of support here today
from the crew thank you guys
you did great
you did great me myself and i all things
considered you did amazing i'm not as
engaged as i usually am because i'm i'm
doing it dan's doing a lot dan's doing a
lot he's he's holding dan is atlas with
the world on his shoulders i didn't have
internet so i like rushed here this
morning because my internet's been out
and i was preparing the doc and then we
decided to talk about the amber herd
thing and i spent hours writing summary
of this thing i know and i didn't even
look at it
you want me to read it now no no you
have to understand that's why i'm a
little out of it let's read it i was now
that way already now's the time wait's
great gracie said ethan thoughts on ace
family taking a gambling sponsorship on
their latest youtube vid
is that right
i'll find out
wait that seems very illegal i love the
family channel gambling crossover the
last videos our five-year-old started a
million dollar business
oh yeah
oh wait wait oh mega awesomener one of
our great mods said
make sure to enable yourself as able to
get gift subs in the settings
also like and subscribe thanks bro you
have to apparently have to enable it
yeah why would you eat it
yeah i think that's right because i saw
someone sharing something like that on
the reddit
uh so here's their latest
okay now
again this video has 600 000 views and
that's a lot of views but first but not
for someone who just bought a half a
million dollar car right who's being
sued three times
i don't understand the money aspect of
their life
but or maybe the kids are hustling they
they start a million dollar business
okay guys so looty's applause oh yeah
they did do gambling
where you can open mystery boxes and get
items up to ninety-five percent off yeah
you can get anything from the newest
sneakers the newest iphone yeah
like a loot box yeah remember jake paul
and ricegum are doing this [ __ ] where
they you could win a you can win a 250
million dollar house remember that was
in the loophole
as you can see here they have all kinds
of mystery boxes they have like apple
yeezy gucci
off-white looty has free and worldwide
shipping with over 1 million customers
and if you uh and if you're under the
age of 12 they're running a special
promotion
type in code grandma's credit card
for a free loot box open all their
products are real and authenticated by
stockx okay guys so we're going to open
our first mystery box we've actually
done this a couple of times so we know
exactly how this works all right sam so
i'm going to pick this mystery box yeah
so this [ __ ] this really crooked crazy
[ __ ] pays a lot of money same with the
steak stuff
so even on like 600 000 views they
probably sell
you know they probably get like [ __ ] 100
200 000 for this no way
yeah yeah yeah maybe
because it's so [ __ ] shady they can't
find big creators to do this
and
it's basically they there's no actual
business so there's no cost of doing
business you know what i mean
like the prices just don't exist on this
[ __ ]
like like i said ricegum and and jake
paul were literally promoting one
where the grand prize was a 250 million
dollar house that they definitely didn't
own
like
it's nuts
but yeah let's watch yeah this this is
this is definitely rock bottom for a
creator
box hopefully has something good in it
um please please for you guys these
families something good please
apple logo sticker oh no
a sticker okay so the good thing about
ludi is if you don't like what you get
you can just sell it back to them and
try it again so i do believe they send
out the stickers i'll be honest about
that
run it back one more time so i'm gonna
go ahead and go with this one
hopefully this one has something good
let's try it again we should do two more
times or three more times two please
please please something good please
so
how this works is they go we want you to
play the game we want you to show one of
you losing and selling it back
and then one of you winning something
big and so they'll they put money in
there for them and they just do it a
bunch of times until
they get the result they want and then
they just use that desktop recording
i mean or if they're super crooked they
just can control it on the back end but
that that's like really crooked
that was my assumption
new iphone an iphone okay so this is an
iphone
13
i don't even have the iphone 13 but the
iphone 13 i hear should we try it again
i love this so the thing is yeah you
just sell the money back and keep
gambling it's like they it's awesome
it's [ __ ] awesome a game
whenever we win we're giving it straight
to the ace devil for supporting us okay
so let's go ahead and go with this
mystery box
and hopefully
we get something good the ps5 i'm
assuming we will get if we win
please
please
ps5
yeah this is definitely dude i feel like
pretty totally rigged yeah right yeah no
it's def it's definitely either
on the back end or
or they just did it a bunch of times
till they won and they have infinite eye
on the back end
but yeah i mean
i would guess your chances of winning
that is probably like
zero
i mean in reality yeah
oh the ultimate gifts that is literally
the best gift
i love that
this is the best gifts yes by the way
ace family if you guys want a free
mystery box right now all you got to do
is use the code ace family right now
click on the screen apple you guys will
give it a try again shout out to ludy
for sponsoring this video and partnering
with us i use family to give back to you
guys and now yeah i mean who else is
partnering with these scam artists
aren't they super related to this
like everyone else do this like four
years ago
what is that on your
um
i guess enough time has passed where
people
um
people are ready for all that
and that fam they are so shameless
they're so disgusting
do you think they won their rolls royce
in a loot box it could be that's a good
guess you know
that's a really good guess
looty
shout out to ludi
you know
[ __ ] love that for them
so here let me read what you've spent
all this time on a b
a b said
the our definition spent a lot of time i
was just
breaking it up let me read it the
defamation trial returns monday morning
after a week of testimony closing
arguments are scheduled for friday
and the jury is set to deliberate guys
guys
guys
guys
wait
what'd you do love you used their code
what did it get
10 cents wait i thought they said you
get a free box
yeah i opened the box and got 10 cents
oh yeah oh you that was fast you got to
do a free box
yeah yeah yeah but they're going to
prevent you from uh like you're not
going to withdraw 10 cents
no except you won't be able to you need
to put in more
you know that's kind of a genius way to
i wonder if you like always win 10 cents
because surely a genius way to
one of you guys should try to make
another account and see if you win 10
cents
because if you could win a box that
easily you could game their [ __ ]
like it took you two seconds to get a
free box
you get a 10 cent ludi gift card that's
[ __ ] sick dude
yo 10 cents bro
that's kind of nuts that's a whole dime
they're just giving away
yo i gotta reflect on that for a minute
[ __ ]
um okay a b continues
today's trial is about shifting [ __ ]
on johnny
is that what it's about ab
you wrote today's trial is about
[ __ ] on johnny grumpy
at least you know copy and paste
interesting uh
synopsis there
more specifically
and it's going to include a orthopedic
surgeon
testifying about depp's finger being
severed he said he didn't believe depp's
account of how the finger was severed
that's interesting
the crazy psychiatrist we saw says depp
showed signs of substance abuse disorder
intimate partner violence that guy's
such a [ __ ] quack um
drinking gatorade dude
i don't know why but that's just that's
that's just hey objection no there's not
listen there's nothing wrong with
gatorade okay i like gate raid but
there's something as an expert witness
psychiatrist
on the stand sipping gatorade dan agree
or disagree gatorade has lots of
electrolytes in it which uh normal tap
water doesn't have so maybe he just
wanted to stay nice and hydrated
you think it's cool that he was sipping
gatorade
unprofessional it's weird it's not weird
he's a psychiatrist he's supposed to be
getting the dudes drinking like icy cold
[ __ ] or like the blue hot blue
gatorade if he was drinking [ __ ]
mountain dew code red i'd be like all
right what the [ __ ] is basically the
same it's not it's not the same dude
gatorade
come on it's just sugar water
sugar water
let's throw it to the pole let's throw
it to the pole sugar water is it
professional for a psychiatrist to be
drinking gatorade on this weird
hey somebody just donated two bucks and
says ten cents is for me i just got i
just i just did it myself
ten cents as well you got 10 you got 10
cents yo
this is crazy everyone's getting 10
cents
is drinking gatorade at
congrats baby unprofessional
yes or no come on you guys know that
shit's weird he's just sipping
the [ __ ]
paul man
which i'm trying to influence drinking
gatorade on the stand well for the
psychiatrist it's a bad pull
oh come on it's a bad pole also it's
important we know what we're talking
about it's a green gatorade
it was green yeah like a radioactive
green
okay well the majority
it's a kind of a split decision here but
the majority no has it
thank you
finally what if it was powerade though
would that make it more or less
professional it's the same [ __ ] honestly
gatorade is funnier than powerade
i for some reason
i just think it's so odd that's it
it's a confusing poll though dan it's a
bad poll
what is confusing an element
okay let's move on um
expert witness another of the same
psychiatrist describes rick's factors of
intimate partner violence shut up
dumbass
dev shows signs of slower processing
speed and impulse control dr spiegel
said i love that this guy's talking all
this [ __ ] he literally doesn't know
anything what did he base it off
watching video clips of him uh him using
an earpiece
that's all based on the fact that he
used to earpiece from what i heard i
didn't catch all of it but uh that's
what the argument he was trying to make
towards the end of it towards the end of
that section so in cross examination i
think the lawyer was right to be like
dude this is not professional for you to
be making this diagnosis based on that
uh spiegel says he is not offering an
iron chair diagnosis oh really
dr spiegel explains that depp has
narcissistic trades okay how much did
they pay for this
an actor that's a narcissist that's not
i've never heard that
that's super rare
okay good wow that was that's really
good right up there abby
uh orthopedic surgeons that's just a
breakdown of each of those points into
further detail oh the ones you already
read
so
okay
interesting
so i'm not going to read it then
yeah
oh cam got 10 cents
whoa everyone's getting 10 cents and
somebody donated two bucks and said i
got a looty box and one ten cents so
everybody's winning 10 cents i think the
theory behind that is that it's just
enough to get you
hooked to get in there and put your
credit card
so they also have 10 cents again they
already approved sorry everyone gets 10
cents in their box it's already been
proven who's they yeah who's there
i mean i don't i don't disbelieve you
but who's they
they
were they
uh one interesting point about the trial
is that kate moss will argue as a
rebuttal witness in defense of johnny
and the only reason she's able to do
that is because amber heard's team or
amber i forget brought her up
mentioning a rumor that johnny threw her
down the stairs now she's able to that's
good defend johnny that's really good
was that his ex or something yes they
used to date i believe in the 90s
that's powerful is she going to come be
like no he didn't he never did that
so shout out kate moss okay
dude john used to be so [ __ ] like
handsome back in the day
um
how old is johnny depp now he's in the
60s let me see
i mean he's still he's still handsome
but
not i mean not not as
but that's what happens right i mean
he's 30 years old you know what i think
the pulled back ponytail isn't doing him
any favors but he's being professional
we'd love that for him
because you know
here he looks great
he got to get that iconic hair
you know
definitely at least 60 man he's an old
man
you know
he had it he had the main free and loose
uh at the beginning of the trial and it
looked better than i think
he had it loose then
yeah hold on let me drop a picture look
at this hunk dude damn what's up player
i'm trying to [ __ ] young johnny depp
what's up dude
i just uh dropped a picture and
discorded one all right started go ahead
let's take a look
oh yeah he got that big
he got that he got a lot of work on that
hair you can tell
they put a lot of time into that dude
you know he's you know johnny probably
has a glam team
in the morning he's just getting ready
because i'll be honest again i know a
lot of people love johnny depp so don't
kill me dude he's innocent okay
but
when people his age do go all out on the
hair
his hair looks younger than his face and
it's it doesn't work
you know what i
mean this is the hair of like a
20 year old
just saying just saying
okay
anyone want to back me up here ian why
are you smiling
go ahead
this is very unrelated well not really
you were making fun of the guy drinking
gatorade yeah
and i was thinking what would be the
most
unprofessional thing to drink yeah
and have you ever heard of belly washers
i haven't what is a belly washer
i google them
i don't know if you can
like this is like
i pulled it up
there's so many and i i remember those
dudes yeah that would no that would be a
shot that would be a sight i just
started to imagine this guy
pulling out like a tweety bird belly
washer yeah
there's basically an amber herd belly
washer which is he's basically just a
simpler
yeah and belly washer is pretty good man
short of just a bottle of whiskey
that's awesome
i don't know where that came from i'm
delirious no that's good that's good i
appreciate that's a good input man
thank you that's a really good input
from ian there
sick with kovid
but his mind is sharp as ever that's
right
ian's comedic mind goes into overdrive
yeah it kind of like you're [ __ ]
squeezed out that's interesting do you
find that you do you think you're
funnier with covet ian is that possible
you know wait you it's funny you say
that because
i saw a post right after we went live on
our subreddit i saved it
and it's literally it just says
ian got caught i can't show it says ian
got covered again [ __ ]
yeah they're chilled
so thanks guys
covet ian was a hit the first time [ __ ]
yeah dude i'm so [ __ ]
that's great news
that's great
would you say that um having covet
improved your gaming abilities
gaming yeah
well i got a i you know i sent this to
love last night
right after my diagnosis
i got on fortnite and i got a fat
[ __ ] dub
[Music]
ninja would have been proud i was
rowing down
sam took off her bra and brought him a
sandwich is that true did sam bring you
a sandwich with braless unprompted
i can't confirm nor deny
the bra but
there was a sandwich oh that's
there you go
um is it possible that you lose the
sense of taste and it sharpens your
other senses
like daredevil
right
you know maybe um
it's hard to say but i'm sure at least
one child through his ipad last night at
least you made him cry bro you made him
break his ipad probably made him piss
his little [ __ ] nappies
there it is
well we're all excited you have covet
apparently so
good job
there's nothing left in this document
literally nothing man
we've been going for three hours we
could just
be done
psychiatrist says
he treats people with substance and
misuse
and intimate partner violence
and he has shown signs in two in my
opinion mr depp has behaviors that are
consistent with both
this guy's such a quack
dr spiegel who also teaches at eastern
virginia medical school
fact check that
that depp's legal team has sought to
paint
spiegel as unqualified to testify
uh yeah dude
um
oh dude crazy
that's all right well i guess that's it
well you guys better watch it soon you
know our videos our views are going up
you guys better watch this episode soon
because it's going to be a race in 24
hours
in it
it is that's right
hey
let's go let's go
thanks olivia let's go and i hope
everyone enjoyed their 10 cent crate
courtesy of the uh
ace family definitely olivia how did you
draw your first step back
yeah i know they're probably looking at
that one and being like yo they they got
a lot of conversions
it's all just people seeing if they get
10 cents from our stream
should i get a snack and continue going
people are saying ethan stay on the view
train that's what i'm saying
can i go to the bathroom at least you
can go to the bathroom i never stop you
from that all right i'm just gonna leave
the camera on you thanks for asking
permission though
let's keep it going
what you train are we talking about
uh we're going to talk about johnny depp
in this expert witness describes
risk factors
of intimate partner violence dr spiegel
he's an expert witness
explain he said i don't want to talk
about all of them okay [ __ ] then what
are you doing up there
but in particular one
having someone in the relationship who's
jealous or
suspicious are you serious i don't think
you can diagnose something with just
he's like listen he only has one
factor he's jealous therefore he's
violent [ __ ] what the [ __ ] you're a
doctor
shut up dr spiegel
you know what spiel means in german
games this man's playing games
that's true by the way
i can confirm
thank you
to having
someone who has a higher than average
acceptance of violent ideation how do
you know that three someone who has
rapid and extreme mood shifts you never
diagnosed him for someone who has
limited self-control you don't even know
him dude
that was a question i had is this guy
actually uh sat down and examined johnny
no that's no problem that's what never
johnny's team is arguing so why the [ __ ]
is even exactly it's just reading second
hand
apparently it's all based on he was like
he had an earphone uh to remember lines
therefore he's on he has cognitive
decline i was like [ __ ]
you're sitting there eating drinking
gatorade talk about
cognitive decline
well he says that and substance abuse
still very vague though spiegel noted
that approximately 40 to 60 percent of
intimate partner violence is committed
under the influence of alcohol
again
so that doesn't prove anything dude just
because he drinks
like damn
they must have paid him a lot of money
that's what i was thinking
expert witnesses get paid a lot
and it's kind of weird because it seems
kind of like
a little shady to pay some doctor
who doesn't know [ __ ] to come testify
but that's why you need a good attorney
right because you have to question their
credibility that's what you do
and this guy is a quack
but if you don't go if you don't have
like a legal crack team
um then he can say whatever the [ __ ] he
wants
and
the jury's not going to be any really
the wiser if you don't have a good
attorney
to to question
do you know what i'm saying yeah 500
median for uh expert testimony i think
that's probably gone up with a that's
with the regular case i don't know what
to be in a case like this
yeah it's it's it's way way up
he's also said
substance use has led depth to have
slower processing speed and lack of
impulse control the psychiatrist said
again do you know him
you've never sat down with him
during the video deposition what was
readily apparent was a gentleman who had
a significant delay in processing speed
he's actually so dumb when you do
depositions you're coached by your
attorneys to be slow because you want to
waste the time
talk slow
think slow
respond slow they only have eight hours
so the more time you waste the better
so like
he seems to be ignoring that when you
have a delayed processing speed many
other cognitive functions are going to
follow under normal conditions depp is
able to control himself but the addition
of chronic drug and alcohol use has led
to adverse behavior shut the [ __ ] up
dude you don't even know him dude
witness say he's not offering armchair
diagnosis
spiegel said on monday his opinion of
death are well within the goldwater rule
which bar armchair
[Music]
psychiatric diagnosis
the defense asks people to define what
the goldwater rule is
um
spiegel said he is not offering any
armchair diagnosis
that is not the case here spiegel said
i've reviewed a lot of professional
a lot of professionals and the
evaluation of their treatment course
video depositions
picture depositions court filings emails
i've reviewed a whole lot of things that
describe
depp and his behavior
do you have the um the you don't you
don't have the uh counter
uh interview here
cross examine
uh no
i want to see this guy get destroyed
dude
he explained that for testifying that he
found depth to display narcissistic
personality traits
uh
dep that whatever shut up spiegel
dep no longer expected to take the stand
on monday man
all right i'm tired
i just want to keep it going for dan
i know dan wants to be here as long as
possible today
someone said as a
psychomatrician what and god's name is
that
as a psychometrician you definitely
cannot attest
to cognitive decline unless doing a
cognitive evaluation very unethical yeah
i mean this seems so he goes i made this
i made this based on emails you read
emails and cited he's in cognitive
decline you've
absolute quack
i don't know
somebody donated fifty dollars with no
message
oh that's just pure love for the game
[ __ ] pure love paul jones shout out
shut up paul jones just pure love for
the game what's up player
i'll give two dollars to av three
dollars to zach
uh five to dan
seven two will get more welcome back oh
olivia gets the most that gets one
dollar sorry buddy
and gets let's see i don't know have i
spent it already
no i'm 50 no definitely not
i'm always left out of these donations
cab you get 10 bucks oh thank you
and then i get the pity points every
time let's go
see you guys i know about this
i wish they would just paraphrase it for
me i could talk about it all day
how do i do that
julie donated 50 dkks
and said i hope you noticed my donkey
kong coins
pretty much the same thing danish crown
oh
shout out
easy love with his his
dance
i hope you noticed my super chat from
earlier it doesn't matter if you read it
out loud or not just wanted to let you
know you did that for me
thanks thanks we didn't read it but
we're reading this one well let's find
it
can you search
all right also we have um
adored piranha says i gotta say i was
upset at the recent rah-rah because i'm
bi
but i know you all are good peeps and uh
have that rough side that we are working
on
stay the course thank you thank you
thank you of course just like george
bush thank you for believing in me
mission accomplished
george bush style
um
someone said all this press about the
lawsuit feels like a distraction from
something else thought stan
yeah they don't want you to know about
[ __ ] crater earth i've been telling
people
the truth is out there we've been trying
to get it out and the media doesn't want
you paying attention so they're going to
blind you with all this johnny depp
amber heard
both schrader earth people when will you
get it wake up to the crater earth wait
are you you're supposed to prepare a
presentation for us about creator earth
how's that going uh
it's
i haven't started lots of ends lots of
outs
i'll help you with the visuals if you
want dan
oh yeah i would love that actually yeah
because that conspiracy
videos are always just like ms paint
quality you know template uh my like
microsoft uh presentation i'll help you
out bring it to the next level oh my god
kekkadar said this is for olivia 50
bucks what do you want me to do guys
please there you go olivia i owe you 50
bucks because this [ __ ] guy how much
yeah
ah cam i beat you you got 10 i got 50.
[ __ ] lose you deserve it you deserve
it you guys if you actually want that
money you have to remind me though like
not keeping tracks
of everyone's [ __ ] i'm not oh yeah do
anything you owe me uh ten thousand
dollars just you know you don't remember
but all right just send me that i'll
take care of it i'll invoice you yeah
you gotta write that down and email me
uh
thank you brian
brianna i appreciate that
all right we gotta go
ten bucks for cam from chelsea
god damn it
oh daniel the 36 year old virgin and i
saw he posted a video
i got to do some research i got to watch
your video
this was the guy that was in our chat
recently yeah he was like don't i don't
know if he but yeah he's 36 year old
virgin right
that's pretty
interesting
have you tried going to a prostitute
just to get it out of the way
there's no shame in that
if i was a 36 year old virgin i would
just go see a prostitute
if it was just that important too you
know
go to a state where it's illegal and
get weird with it
let's go
all right um my throat's starting to
hurt i better wrap it up
guys wednesday is actually going to be a
good episode
the olivia comeback activities are fire
fire fire and everyone will be back in
the studio right on wednesday well not
ian
not ian of course not again
and not yet
and hopefully nobody else gets sick in
the next 48 hours oh boy
i'm in my immune phase right now
right she just got over it
a couple weeks ago how was your covet
olivia
it was
i felt like i had a cold but emotionally
was horrible because it was during
senior week
but um it wasn't
the activities once i was negative so it
was it was fine just a lot of crying
well that ian seems to be experiencing
that same symptom
hmm just crying lots of ex did you have
existential dread did you think about
pinocchio and the whale
no
no
no from olivia
you know what
who's to say
maybe
alrighty
excellent
wow this is the worst episode we've ever
done i think
it's up there yeah it's definitely up
there man
[ __ ] dude tiptoe saturday
get your [ __ ] ass up and work
actually
we should all
we if we do tiptoes on a weekend we
should all
put our feet and shoes and be and do our
own rules of the lifetime our knees in
the shoes you know
[Laughter]
or or if we're all sitting on the couch
we could put a drape like a blanket that
looks like a couch and then just have
tiny feet on it
just something to pay homage to the
tippy toes to the role of a lifetime
yeah so the command performance yeah i
mean that defined his career didn't he
win an academy award for that i think so
best supporting actor in the role of a
lifetime yeah
gary coleman
with his knees and shoes not caring
yeah
gary i know his name's gary oldman yeah
it's so close it's closed but it's just
because gary
yeah he's a little he's little person
i mean
that's funny but it doesn't have
anything to do with that they're just
they're they do have very similar their
names are very close to each other yeah
well let it slide
another ten dollars for olivia and i
think i saw another one stop it
alfredo and shredder
yeah what do you guys think that should
be this episode is a gem among the worst
bts tiptoes and costumes please
that'd be great i do remember that um
before i worked for you guys when i
would watch the shows and you guys would
say that it was the worst episode ever
those were always my favorite
i 100 agree with what olivia just not
this one but not this one
because like we had like an hour of just
dead air at the very beginning yeah like
unwatchable dude
holy [ __ ]
you could the views were very low as
well very low the live views
what was that olivia
oh in the time stamps you could put the
boring parts you could say put this one
in two times speed
well no we were going to say dead air
just skip this skip skip this part yeah
another 10 saying it's the best worst
episode ever five dollars for zach for
the rolex fund five dollars oh my god
jasper shout out yo
thank you
thank you
all right i'm gonna actually go
so on wednesday we're gonna have a
actually a good episode okay guys
oh we'll see all right all right see you
guys then whatever this was
apparently this is a podcast
of some sorts
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
da
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody